votre domicile le matin vous a empêché
de répondre à notre convocation nous
sommes donc particulièrement heureux de
pouvoir enfin vous entendre en préambule
de notre audition et compte tenu des
éléments que je viens de mentionner je
vous indique notre commission d'enquête
ne doit pas interférer mais vous le
savez avec la procédure judiciaire en
cours nous ne sommes pas là pour
qualifier des faits en référence à des
infractions éventuelles pénales ce qui
relèverait de la compétence exclusive de
l'autorité judiciaire notre commission
d'enquête a pour seul objet de se
pencher sur la préparation la mise en
oeuvre et le contrôle du fond Marianne
et d'un évaluer les résultats comme cela
est naturel s'agissant d'une politique
publique mise en oeuvre après un
événement particulièrement dramatique
que chacun d'entre nous garde en mémoire
à cet égard nous souhaitons savoir
comment vous avez été amené à présenter
un dossier en réponse au fond Marianne
le préfet Gravel nous indiqué lors de
son audition que vous représentiez une
caution scientifique évidente je le cite
vous pourrez nous indiquer si ce
qualificatif semble adéquats et nous
expliquer plus précisément la manière
dont vous avez ensuite été impliqué en
termes de mise en œuvre ainsi que les
résultats que vous estimez à avoir
obtenu avant de vous céder la parole
pour un bref propos introductif je dois
si vous le souhaitez bien entendu je
dois vous rappeler qu'un faux témoignage
devant une commission d'enquête est
possible de sanctions pénales qui
peuvent aller selon les circonstances de
3 à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et de 45000
euros d'amende je vous invite donc à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité levez la main droite
et dites je le jure
je vous laisse si vous le souhaitez
maintenant la parole pour un propos
introductif je remercie monsieur le
Président
je vais être assez bref donc quelques
minutes pour expurger surtout
un certain nombre de points
qui me tiennent à cœur
et que vous avez commencé d'une certaine
façon à rappeler
je ne suis dupe de rien mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je suis dupe de
rien
et sans préambule car votre temps est
précieux je vais entrer donc dans le vif
du sujet en toute transparence
je vais parler en toute transparence
pour vous donner les éléments afin que
vous puissiez vous approcher de la
vérité au plus près
mais je vais parler en toute
transparence pour dire aussi des choses
qui me déplaisent que j'ai entendu que
j'ai écouté et que je ne peux laisser
passer
je vais probablement j'espère pas je
vais probablement alimenter la polémique
à travers à travers ce que je vais vous
dire
j'aurais préféré franchement ne pas
m'exprimer ainsi mais malheureusement
comme souvent dans ce type d'affaires
l'un des sens l'emporte sur la raison
et sur la retenue
je le dis mesdames et messieurs devant
vous tous sous serment
et devant l'opinion publique
non non
et non le sujet qui intéresse votre
commission d'enquête n'est pas
l'expression de la République des
copains pour reprendre le propos
scandaleux car insultant et diffamatoire
utilisé par l'un de vos collègues
sur une chaîne de télévision en
l'occurrence publique Sénat
je parle de vous monsieur le sénateur
Daniel Bruyer il n'y a pas eu de
copinage dans cette affaire et je vous
prie Monsieur le Président de rappeler à
vos collègues la décence qui exige cette
affaire ne serait-ce pour la mémoire de
la victime que vous avez cité
le premier copinage qui devrait
d'ailleurs être dénoncé c'est celui qui
lit votre courant politique celui des
écologistes alislamisme et ceux dans
plusieurs villes de France
voilà l'intitulé d'une vraie commission
d'enquête permettez-moi l'expression qui
aurait de la gueule si j'ose dire
je passe ce premier point parce qu'il
fallait l'expurger
ainsi je ne puis tolérer et je le dis
calmement
et je pense qu'aucun démocrate ne peut
le tolérer que l'on puisse lorsqu'on est
sénateur
élu parce que la chose a concerné aussi
l'autre chambre certains députés
et lorsqu'on est de surcroît membre
d'une commission d'enquête tenir dans la
presse des propos accusatoires avant
même la fin des travaux de cette même
commission d'enquête je puis vous dire
donc mon indignation car ce type de
procédé qui se substitue à la justice
nosore ni son auteur ni l'exercice
démocratique je ne fais aucun amalgame
parce que je sais que la majorité des
sénateurs et des parlementaires ont eu
une attitude de dignité je ferme donc
cette première parenthèse
depuis plus de deux mois
j'assiste impuissant à ce piétinement
d'une sacro-sainte valeurs la
présomption d'innocence
alors que nous sommes aujourd'hui d'un
point de vue pénal au stade de
l'ouverture d'une information judiciaire
certains juges utiles dirigés déjà des
bûchers
je vous rappelle que seule la justice
accuse vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président
votre rôle ici vous le connaissez
parfaitement j'en suis conscient
et il ne consiste donc pas à accuser il
sera
utile de le rappeler à chacune des
étapes
avant de répondre à vos questions
mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs avant de livrer ma vérité
en toute transparence
je souhaiterais quand même remettre les
gens les enjeux au centre du village si
j'ose dire sans me dérober et sont
invités aucune question
je suis sous serment je l'ai rappelé et
vous le savez
il y a eu sans doute sans doute des
erreurs partagées dans cette affaire
et je vous ferai part au fur et à mesure
des griefs que j'ai moi-même contre les
uns et les autres les politiques
l'administration
mais contrairement à d'autres je ne suis
pas venu ici pour défendre une carrière
je ne suis pas venu ici
pour faire de la communication
je ne suis pas venu ici pour me
justifier comme ce justifierait un
coupable parce que je ne suis coupable
de rien d'un point de vue pénal je le
répète
le fond est le plus grave à mes yeux
c'est ce que je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui
et j'ai des grilles
on s'attaque à une ministre
de la République
en vérité on s'attaque un gouvernement
au mépris de la vérité parfois
non je le dis
Marlène chapanay pas mon ami elle l'a
pas été hier et elle le sera encore
moins demain
mais non Marlène Schiappa
n'écoutable ni de détournement d'argent
ni d'un quelconque copinage je le
précise
je vous dirai
de quoi est-elle responsable à mes yeux
politiquement parlant
on s'attaque à l'honneur d'un préfet
Christian Gravel
mais en vérité on est en train de
s'attaquer à l'honneur de toute une
administration
je ne suis pas en fonctionnaire je suis
un citoyen engagé
je ne suis pas un haut fonctionnaire
mais je suis scandalisé par la manière
comment laquelle
au-delà des erreurs qu'il est légitime
de rechercher on cherche et le terme a
été utilisé me semble-t-il ici même à
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain
Christian Gravel que je connais depuis
au moins une quinzaine d'années
est en républicain de conviction et un
homme de grande valeur
il n'écoutable d'aucun détournement de
fonds
que j'aurais pu percevoir de
détournement de fond
on pourra discuter plus tard des choses
qui pourraient peut-être être un sujet
de discussion et de départ
on s'attaque enfin un homme
ma personne
on s'attaque à mon honneur et à ma
réputation
je l'avoue ce n'est pas nouveau surtout
depuis que le populisme
et que certaines presse s'est mise au
service de ce populisme et devenu à la
mode
mais au-delà de ma personne
l'on s'attaque surtout un courant de
pensée celui qui croit la République
celui qui croit la laïcité et celui qui
n'a pas peur d'exprimer clairement ses
positions contre l'islam politique
donc c'est un processus de délitimation
mais soyez conscient au-delà de tout
il s'agit de s'attaquer à une action une
impérieuse nécessité me semble-t-il qui
nous enjoint de lutter contre l'islam
politique
véritable fléau qui ne cesse de
gangrener nos sociétés
et permettez-moi de vous le dire ainsi
quand je vois certaine l'acheter je
comprends tous les jours pourquoi cette
islamisme continue de gangrener cette
société
ce fléau vous le savez probablement
trouve aujourd'hui des relais quoi qu'on
puisse en dire et des complices y
compris au sein d'une partie de la
sphère politique au sein de la société
civile et parfois malheureusement au
sein des systèmes médiatiques
sclérosiers globalement médiocre qui
alimente le populisme et qui s'est mis
lui-même au niveau des réseaux sociaux
avec fermeté donc je tiens à démentir
catégoriquement toutes les accusations
graves et mensongères les approximations
et les contre-vérités qui ont été
relayées
et qui a suscité la naissance de votre
commission mais aussi malheureusement à
travers un pathétique et j'y reviendrai
rapport de l'Inspection générale de
l'administration instruit exclusivement
à charge avec des approximations des
assimilations graves et là aussi des
mensonges
j'espère que mon intervention permettra
de mettre un bémol un peu de nuance à
cette folie quasi généralisée qui
entoure cette histoire ou des
accusations tranchées sont proférées
dans un esprit le plus souvent de
règlement de comptes et de vendetta
idéologiques pour finir en quelques mots
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs permettez-moi de
parler un peu à la première personne ni
voyez là aucune forme de prétention ou
d'arrogance mais la nécessité de vous
dire clairement qui je suis
quels sont mes valeurs et quelles sont
mes principes
je suis un farouche opposant et
peut-être qu'on vous l'a dit à tous les
extrémismes les islamistes bien sûr mais
aussi à tous les tenants de toutes les
formes de populisme c'est ce qui a
structuré mon long parcours de
journalistes engagés c'est ce qui a
nourri mon expression
c'est la raison pour laquelle mes
détracteurs se ramassent aujourd'hui à
la pelle
c'est la raison pour laquelle aussi
depuis une trentaine d'années mesdames
et messieurs je n'ai pas eu droit à une
vie normale
la mienne a été jonchée de cadavres elle
a été jenchée de sang
la mienne a été alimentée de menaces de
mort
ma vie n'est pas celle à laquelle aspire
n'importe quelle paire de famille
mes enfants contrairement aux vôtres
n'ont pas grandi dans une
on peut pas grandit dans un contexte
normal
ils ont grandi avec des policiers
postés parfois 24 heures de sur 24
devant leur domicile comme s'il
s'agissait d'une ambassade
presque
une espèce de citadelle siégé avec un
père accompagné lui-même obligé d'être
accompagné lui-même de garde du corps
depuis 2003 lors de ses moindres
déplacements
ceux qui même sont obligés de supporter
la vie qui est la mienne car la France
aujourd'hui
car dans la France d'aujourd'hui on ne
peut plus s'exprimer librement
malheureusement
surtout lorsqu'on s'attaque aux
extrémistes et singulièrement lorsqu'on
vise l'islam politique je n'ai pas à
construire ma vie autour des questions
matérielles je vous le dis mais j'ai
consacré celle-ci à défendre des valeurs
universelles et humanistes je n'ai pas
bâti mes relations à travers une logique
de copinage intéressée
ce qui défendent la République ceux qui
défendent la laïcité et ceux qui
rejettent sincèrement l'islamisme sont
tous mes copains pour reprendre
l'expression de votre collègue
et vous comprendrez Mesdames et
Messieurs que certains ne peuvent pas
être mes copains lorsqu'ils ne défendent
pas ces valeurs
et c'est mieux ainsi
lorsque l'année dernière on m'a proposé
pour une décoration je l'ai refusé même
s'il paraît qu'on ne refuse pas une
décoration je l'ai refusé parce que je
n'attends ni récompense ni honneur ni
argent ni aucun privilège en revanche en
revanche mesdames et messieurs
j'exige oui j'exige du respect
j'exige du respect monsieur
un respect similaire à celui que je vous
témoigne à tous
en votre qualité d'élus
en votre qualité de femme et d'hommes
un respect similaire à celui que j'ai
toujours témoigné pour cette république
que vous incarnez et que je n'aurai de
cesse de défendre
merci Monsieur Sifaoui comme vous le
voyez je vous ai laissé un certain temps
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
d'intervention et si je vais vous
accuser d'être dans un camping âge et si
je l'ai fait c'est surtout parce que
jusqu'à présent vous n'aviez pas eu
l'occasion de vous exprimer publiquement
sur des sujets ou effectivement vous
avez été mise en cause dès le départ si
je puis dire
je voudrais tout de même avant de passer
à
ce qui relie aujourd'hui c'est à dire
cet homme de question précise
je voudrais vous dire et qu'il y a
quelques propos
qui ne peuvent pas fonctionner
l'un de ses propos
ne pas se traiter ici il a
l'intérêt d'être
dip publiquement et sur votre ressenti
concernant les propos d'un de nos
collègues de cette de cette mission
parce que les choses peuvent se traiter
autrement
vous avez parlé
de l'utiliser le mot on s'attaque
faudrait être bien au clair sur un point
c'est que cette commission d'enquête de
s'attaque à personne
voilà elle ne s'attaque pas à un
ministre encore au moins un gouvernement
elle établit les faits
elle pose des questions elle écoute les
réponses elle en tire des conclusions
tout ça ne pas s'attaquer
bien entendu je ne crois pas que vous
auriez pu entendre qui que ce soit par
les de détournement d'argent pour madame
la ministre
de copinage de manière générale sauf une
citation que vous avez faite
c'est pas notre notre sujet ici
la même façon on sait pas attaqué au
préfet de Gravel
en rien
moi je respecte apporteur tous les
membres de cette commission respectent
les préfets de la République
on a simplement posé des questions
sur des points de procédure
et méthodes administratives des façons
de faire
et des résultats
on est dans notre rôle
et en faisant ça ça n'enlève rien aux
qualités propres de la personne
nous avons toujours considéré qu'il peut
y avoir dans une vie de qualité de
chacun d'entre nous d'ailleurs des
moments où il peut y avoir des erreurs
qui sont commises voilà on a même fait
nous un texte de loi sur cela la prise
en compte
pardon du droit à l'erreur
elle était loin mais voilà
nul homme n'est parfait
et il peut y avoir un moment ou un autre
d'une carrière des difficultés
particulières nous les avons pointé nous
les pointerons dans notre rapport
et c'est tout c'est notre rôle c'est
ensuite à l'administration de dire ce
qu'elle a à dire c'était le rapport de
l'Inspection générale de
l'administration des prix de décision
personnelle qui ne relève pas de nous
mais en aucune façon vous pourrez
prendre le script exact de tout ce que
nous avons dit à n'a aucune façon nous
ne sommes dans un système d'attaque de
qui que ce soit
et vous le verrez d'ailleurs dans votre
dans notre audition nous nous
attaquerons pas à vous non plus nous
demanderons à établir des faits nous
questionnerons
et vous nous répondrez aussi précisément
que vous le voudrez
ceci étant dit
je vais démarrer par quelques questions
peut-être monsieur le rapporteur
excusez-moi pardon merci monsieur le
Président je veux
pour dire consolider même s'il y en a
pas besoin le propos que vient de tenir
le président Claude Raynal m'associer je
partage la totalité de ce qu'il a dit
et je vais simplement pour la forme
faire de remarques comme je l'ai fait
hier d'ailleurs
à l'issue de du propane productif de la
ministre madame Schiappa il faut pas
confondre les temps les lieux et les
procédures nous sommes ici dans une
commission d'enquête parlementaire en
l'occurrence sénatoriale il y a deux
autres procédures une devant le parquet
national financier il y a une autre
inspection générale de l'administration
moi je porte pas de jugement
j'entends ce que vous ressentez mais
c'est devant ces deux instances je les
appelais ou institutions que vous avez à
mon avis à leur faire part de votre
sentiment nous sommes ici dans un temps
de contrôle le plus abouti de
l'action du gouvernement et de la
dépense publique sur un sujet qui est un
sujet
évidemment important on le mesure et je
ne vais je ne mélange pas les gens nous
avons des parcours les uns les autres
qui sont différents des vies différentes
vous l'avez dit faites de haut et de bas
et nous devons ici à cet instant nous
extraire de cette condition dans la
mesure du possible pour établir analyser
comprendre et tenter de bien identifier
la réalité des faits et de faire émerger
la vérité pour tirer les enseignements
que dans le cas de notre commission
d'enquête en tant que sénateur nous
souhaitons livrer dans un rapport pour
qu'il soit évidemment rendu public à
l'attention de toutes celles et ceux qui
ont
eu à connaître en tant qu'acteur mais
également vis-à-vis des français puisque
sur la mission qui est la lutte contre
le combat contre les discours
séparatistes je pense que nous sommes
animés tous de cette volonté de faire
reculer
ces discours séparatistes
merci monsieur le rapporteur nous allons
démarrer évidemment par l'origine du
fond Marianne alors vous l'avez dit
à l'instant vous avez des relations
anciennes avec le préfet Gravel vous
avez dit une quinzaine d'années je pense
que ça ça a pris de la plus de
consistance en avançant évidemment
vous attend associé d'une façon ou d'une
autre aux travaux préparatoires en vous
consultant sur certains aspects de sa
création nous savons que vous avez
participé en tant qu'expert sur les
réflexions sur la loi est-ce que ça a
été plus loin ensuite sur la création de
fonds Marianne
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur avant de répondre juste un
point pour que mon propos soit très
clair j'ai utilisé le on impersonnel je
ne visais aucunement votre commission
d'enquête mais je répondais à l'ambiance
générale afin aussi même si peut-être la
plupart d'entre vous n'ont pas besoin
que vous soyez quand même assez vigilant
par rapport à l'ambiance qui entoure
cette affaire l'ambiance toxique je
dirais qui entoure cette affaire je
ferme la parenthèse nous sommes
parfaitement compris me semble-t-il
alors le contexte
qui m'a amené à
à rencontrer le cabinet de Madame la
Ministre Marlène Schiappa et le suivant
d'abord je tiens à vous dire
que depuis les attentats du 11 septembre
j'ai été sollicité de façon régulière
par plusieurs institutions
j'ai répondu toujours favorablement et
bénévolement je tiens à préciser à ce
titre que tout au long de ma carrière je
n'ai jamais bénéficier d'un seul centime
de fond public ni sollicité ni agit
d'aucune manière dans un dans une
logique de rémunération et ce jusqu'à
l'année qui intéresse
le sujet que vous traitez
je ne vais pas vous faire le long
parcours de consultation diverses et
variées que ce soit sous le regretté
Jacques Chirac
sous l'ancien président Nicolas Sarkozy
sous le président François Hollande et
évidemment sous l'actuel président
d'Emmanuel Macron
j'ai été reçu à maintes reprises par
plusieurs institutions régaliennes qui
s'intéressent à la thématique qui est la
sienne qui est partout qui est la mienne
et qui est celle de beaucoup d'autres
personnes qui travaillent sur cette
thématique je n'ai pas été
la seule personne à être consulté
à partir des années 2015-2016 la
pression terroriste
s'étend accentué
la manifestation de ce qu'on a appelé la
menace intérieure le terrorisme
domestique
s'est révélé avec acuité
on a vu que ce que je présageais
malheureusement au début des années 2000
sur le fait que cette évolution allait
donner lieu
incontestablement à des actions
terroristes perpétré par des citoyens
français contre d'autres citoyens
français chose qui était totalement
inaudible au début des années 2000
je vous le dis trivialement en prenez un
peu pour un cinglé lorsque je disais
qu'il allait avoir des attentats des
décapitations et des gens qui allaient
tirer à la kalachnikov dans les rues de
Paris je l'ai écrit je l'ai dit je l'ai
je l'ai annoncé sur des faits objectifs
à partir de 2015 je me suis dit que la
société a pris conscience mais surtout
les décideurs politiques qui souvent
face à ce sujet de l'Islam politique on
fait preuve sinon de calcul de mes
connaissances voire parfois clairement
de l'acheter politique
2015-2016
donc la situation
malheureuse permet à tout un chacun de
prendre conscience du danger terroriste
il y avait un autre aspect qui n'était
pas du tout traité c'est la question
idéologique de l'islam politique je me
suis donc attelé à partir de 2016 à
travailler inlassablement sur la
question idéologique substrat des
actions terroristes que nous subissions
et qui n'était pas véritablement prise
en compte en tant que tel c'est-à-dire
autant la menace terroriste avait
suscité la naissance d'une doctrine
d'État qui s'est manifesté par
évidemment des actions policières de
renseignement et de justice
et où la société civile n'avait pas
grand chose à faire sinon à essayer de
je dirais d'alerter des
sur des comportements sur suspects etc
notamment chez la jeunesse ce qu'on aura
appelé après les signaux faibles la
question idéologique n'était pas du tout
traitée et moi je n'ai toujours pensé
que il fallait
imaginer deux choses c'est ériger une
vraie doctrine
anti-islamiste une vraie doctrine
antislamiste c'est-à-dire assumer un
combat idéologique contre l'islam
politique qui nous mène un combat qui
mène un combat à toutes les démocraties
et surtout mettre en place des
mécanismes de prévention de la
radicalisation et des mécanismes de
contre narration notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux
d'autant plus que les mouvements
toxiques les mouvements extrémistes en
tous déployés une propagande
extraordinaire depuis la naissance des
réseaux sociaux et ont pris de cours et
de vitesse
les États et donc la France évidemment
était de ce point de vue là très en
retard à partir de l'année je dirais
permettez-moi de livrer un certain
nombre de détails à l'enquête pénale
donc je ne citerai pas de nom et je
citerai d'autant plus pas de nom que
chaque nom qui sort et soumis
aujourd'hui au lynchage que j'ai au
lynchage médiatique et populiste de
certains courants politiques que j'ai
cité tout à l'heure donc je citerai pas
de nom mais en tout état de cause j'ai
été reçu par un certain nombre de aux
responsables j'ai été reçu avec d'autres
en même temps que d'autres séparément à
plusieurs reprises dans plusieurs
ministères dans plusieurs cabinets par
plusieurs conseillers par plusieurs
personnalités par plusieurs ministres
etc
la question c'était que doit-on faire à
votre avis
pour faire face à cette pression
islamiste qui se manifeste de
différentes façons c'est une question
qui me semble-t-il a été a été
posée à tous ceux qui travaillent sur ce
sujet qui ont été reçus
à partir de
l'été 2020
à partir de l'été 2020
je après la nomination de Madame Marlène
Schiappa au comme ministre délégué à la
citoyenneté
j'apprends qu'un certain nombre de c'est
d'abord j'apprends qu'un de ces de ces
collaborateurs de ces de ces conseillers
étaient intéressés de avoir un échange
avec moi un échange intellectuel c'est
je vais appeler le conseiller 1 je leur
ai donné voilà on va l'appeler
conseiller ce conseil 1 je vais rentrer
en contact avec lui à partir du mois de
septembre d'abord par texto ensuite
téléphoniquement ensuite on va se
rencontrer physiquement on va échanger
nous allons faire le constat que
évidemment je m'en faisais aucun doute
j'avais aucun doute sur sac le
défendions les mêmes valeurs les mêmes
idées la République la laïcité etc
cette nécessité de
de d'agir mais surtout j'ai compris une
chose c'est qu'il y avait une traduction
politique à partir de 2020 un vrai
changement de doctrine c'est qui me
d'ailleurs qui qui allait dans le sens
que j'ai toujours défendu c'est que
l'État allait enfin
affronter l'islam politique l'idéologie
islamiste et mettre les moyens
politiques pour
répondre à la propagande islamiste de
plus en plus pressante
[Musique]
contre la France contre la République
contre les institutions contre les élus
contre les universitaires contre les
journalistes etc
évidemment lorsque je vois cette
réorientation
de la politique
étatique c'est une chose que j'ai
toujours défendue je décide de la
soutenir je la soutiens d'abord
intellectuellement je la soutiens en
tant que que personne engagée
et j'exprime ce soutien de différentes
façons sur les réseaux sociaux dans mes
publications dans mes émissions télé etc
à partir
de la rentrée 2020 le président de la
République va tenir un discours
important au Mureaux le discours des
Mureaux contre les séparatisme
islamistes et là les choses vont
s'accélérer
quelques jours plus tard
l'assassinat du professeur du collège
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
évidemment l'émotion légitime et
d'une certaine façon
une volonté politique qui était déjà
affichée qui s'accentue à ce moment-là
et qui évidemment
qui est interpelle les pouvoirs publics
à agir très vite
concours de circonstances au moment où
la politique gouvernementale va faire
cette
je dirais volonté de de répondre à la
propagande islamiste sur Internet on
découvre deux choses on découvre d'abord
que le crime terroriste qui a quitté la
vie à ce professeur
était lié
de façon directe et matérialisée par la
propagande islamique sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est à dire qu'en 11 jours
ce professeur a été diabolisé en 11
jours on a utilisé le discours
victimaire et en 11 jours seulement
quelqu'un qui n'était pas du tout en
contact avec les gens qui
diabolisaient cette victime
aller passer à l'acte on connaît la
suite donc le constat en fait que
personnellement j'avais porté j'avais
fait j'étais pas le seul évidemment
ce matérialisé par un fait dramatique
deuxième
événement de hasard le 2 ou le 3 octobre
au moment du discours des Mureaux
Christian Gravel est nommé au cipdr
bon à partir de là j'ai trois types de
rencontres
j'ai des rencontres au ministère de
l'Intérieur
et j'ai des rencontres aussi PDR avec
d'autres mais disons les rencontres les
plus les plus régulières se font avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur le département
de Madame Schiappa notamment et
Christian Gravel et ça se fait de façon
je dirais concomitante et à partir de là
parce que je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses qui se sont dites
ce que je peux documenter et et
l'enquête pénale démontrera il y a eu
des rencontres régulières à la demande à
la demande encore une fois à la demande
du cabinet de Madame Schiappa je n'ai
jamais sollicité un rendez-vous pour
aller faire des offres de services
les différents conseillers celui que
j'ai appelé conseiller a avec lequel
j'ai une relation très cordiale
aujourd'hui parce que jamais agi de
façon qui pourrait me laisser penser
qu'il y avait
quelque chose de malsain
ces personnes travaillent pour la
République
le conseiller je dirais 4 que j'avais
rencontré quelques mois plus tard plutôt
au cpdr avant même l'arrivée de
Christian Gravel parce que j'étais aussi
en contact avec le prédécesseur de
Christian Gravel
le conseiller 3
et enfin le conseiller 2 les quatre
conseillers avec lesquels je vais être
en contact de façon régulière entre je
dirais les mois de septembre octobre
novembre décembre janvier
février mars jusqu'à jusqu'au mois
d'avril et tout ce processus se passe
sur deux sujets d'abord des
consultations pour alimenter la ministre
dans le cadre de tout ce qui est
compréhension de la future loi
séparatisme etc enfin de ce qui allait
être la loi séparatisme etc ça c'est
l'alimenter afin qu'elle comprenne quels
étaient les enjeux etc donc ils ont
rencontré un certain nombre de d'acteurs
dont moi-même et ensuite
la demande de leur part une demande de
leur part
disant que il sera intéressé que je
puisse traduire des éléments ou les
idées les pistes que Geoffrey que je
leur proposais mais pour moi je
proposais des pistes des réflexions pour
qu'ils s'en emparent et qu'ils en face
qui veulent à aucun moment je me suis
dit tiens je vais proposer un projet
pour moi
et tout ça à ce stade se fait
gracieusement encore une fois donc à
partir de là une précision parce qu'on
va on va
oublier de préciser les choses je vous
en prie
vous avez donc vous êtes peu exprimé
oralement mais vous avez tweeté un petit
peu
dans un tweet vous dites ce que vous
venez de rappeler je n'ai pas pris cette
initiative spontanément c'est ce que
vous nous répète tout ça aujourd'hui j'y
étais encouragé par des représentants
des pouvoirs publics notamment par les
membres du cabinet de Madame Schiappa
c'est ce que je veux dire je vous le
souligne un nouveau sincèrement
aujourd'hui et vous rajoutez et paraît
le même
si vous pouvez un peu nous développer ce
point
les rencontres avec Madame Schiappa
désolé parce que au-delà de la chose et
de sa gravité
je suis quelqu'un d'assez jovial donc
quand il y a des choses me font rire je
ris et désolé de rire parce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure elle sera
d'autant
elle sera pas elle n'est pas mon ami
elle n'a pas été elle est pas
aujourd'hui elle sera encore moins
demain vous savez pourquoi j'ai dit ça
je devais pas le dire dis ça parce que
je n'aime pas les gens qui n'ont pas de
courage
je ne respecte pas les gens qui n'ont
pas de courage je vous l'ai dit Madame
Schiappa est innocente mais je l'ai dit
deux dès le départ son attitude est
curieuse elle a une attitude de
quelqu'un qui est coupable mais elle est
coupable de rien et je le redis devant
vous et je lui je lui redis
nous ne parlons pas de culpabilité donc
elle a une attitude de coupable c'est
moi qui le dis là son attitude si
j'étais un observateur extérieur de
cette affaire je dis tiens madame
Schiappa quelque chose à se reprocher et
c'est bizarre elle n'a rien à se
reprocher écoutez c'est pas à vous de le
dire devant je vous donne mon sentiment
de votre point de vue voilà mais
revenons au fait vous dites et par
Madame Schiappa donc vous avez été
encouragé par Madame Schiappa si ce que
vous avez dit tout à fait est-ce que
vous le confirmez ou pas et qu'est-ce
comment ça s'est traduit ça c'est
traduit par des rencontres alors
effectivement on s'est rencontré des
rencontres enfin de réunion avec son
cabinet et je vais citer deux rencontres
notamment ou à l'issue de réunion qui
porte sur le projet
que j'ai proposé d'abord que j'ai plus
tard d'accord quand ta mini sort pour
vous saluer et pour vous dire je compte
sur vous
est-ce que c'est encouragé à mettre en
application un projet ou pas quand les
conseillers de la ministre vous disent
la ministre apprécie énormément le
projet que vous nous avez présenté
elle croit en ce projet elle s'en
inspire énormément
et vous encourage à le présenter et à le
défendre
et il sera regardé avec bienveillance
etc c'est autre chose non mais attendez
troisièmement lorsque à l'issue de
d'une rencontre que je devais avoir avec
elle effectivement le 22 avril
le 22 avril elle devait me recevoir pour
que nous puissions parler de ce projet
en tête-à-tête finalement cette
rencontre a été annulée en raison d'un
agenda compliqué où elle était retenue
je crois avec le président de la
République le Premier ministre de
mémoire elle arrive enfin de rendez-vous
avec son directeur de cabinet monsieur
Sébastien Jallet
elle me salue et elle me dit encore une
fois qu'elle compte sur moi quel compte
sur moi et qu'elle m'encourage vivement
à le mettre en application le plus vite
possible et que ça sera vu étudier etc
alors je mets un bémol et c'est pour ça
que je veux aller vers la précision
c'est vrai qu'à aucun moment ni madame
Schiappa ni son cabinet non pris un
engagement financier à mon égard jamais
jamais
il y a eu deux étapes une étape de d'un
processus de réflexion qui a amené au
projet une présentation par moi-même du
projet
que j'ai finalement décidé parce que je
me suis dit
si j'ai toujours défendu cette idée je
ne vois pas pourquoi je
l'appliquerai pas et la troisième étape
donc de validation politique si j'ose
dire il y a une validation politique de
la part de Madame Schiappa et du cabinet
madame Schiappa il restait une dernière
étape c'est de la validation
administrative et financière du projet
donc le projet son état de financement
initial j'ai entendu une histoire de
300.000 euros pour moi ça ça n'a pas de
sens et je vais vous dire pourquoi ça a
pas de sens ça ne va pas résister à un
examen froid distancié et documenté de
de la chronologie que je vais vous citer
dans le détail ça ne va pas résister
c'est pas possible il y a pas eu on n'a
jamais parlé de 300000 euros jamais
attendez je pense que on va y revenir
moi je voudrais deux enfin je fais une
observation à ce stade
les déclarations que vous faites sur les
discussions ou les rencontres avec
Madame Schiappa
semble-t-il vous confirmer les
déclarations de la ministre hier qui
explique que c'est plutôt et vous l'avez
dit je dis pas entre deux portes mais
c'est assez furtif ça n'est dans aucun
des éléments où vous venez de nous
donner ça n'est pas notre entretien
d'une demi-heure une heure ou le projet
discutait en tête-à-tête avec des
conseillers ça c'est le premier aimant
mais je voudrais revenir parce que vous
avez dit à partir du 2 octobre monsieur
Gravel est nommé comme secrétaire
général du cpdr et alors il y a de
manière suivie un certain nombre de
d'échanges de rencontre est-ce que vous
pouvez nous communiquer aujourd'hui ou
très rapidement
des preuves de parce que logiquement
vous avez des rendez-vous fixés donc
vous devez avoir une chronologie des
dates et certainement d'ailleurs avec
l'administration à ce niveau de
responsabilité des mails de confirmation
sur ces rencontres parce que à l'heure
actuelle moi je prends note de votre
déclaration d'un certain nombre de
contacts suivi et réguliers avec les
autorités je veux dire comme ça
politique et administratives et j'ai
juste besoin ça nous permet là encore
pour objectiver l'effet et les séquencer
dans le temps de bien comprendre donc si
vous pouvez soit tout de suite soit à
l'issue de cette audition nous faire
suivre des éléments tangibles qui
confirment votre déclaration merci j'ai
désolé de de ne pas pouvoir donner
aujourd'hui je voulais pour tout vous
dire je les avais préparé
au moment où je les avais préparé
avant-hier j'avais toute une
documentation avec laquelle je devais
venir
j'ai reçu une visite très courtoise de
la part du juge d'instruction et
et représentant du parc de la représente
du parquet et des policiers qui ont
effectivement tous saisis et mis sous CD
tout ce qui concernait enfin tous les
documents que j'avais déjà préparés qui
concernent cette affaire donc il faut
que je puisse
à la fois reconnecter l'ensemble des
éléments l'ensemble des traces
numériques etc et je vous communiquerai
des dates dès que possible par un envoi
mail mais ce que je puis vous ce que je
peux vous dire pardon monsieur le
Président non je crois qu'il faut
maintenant qu'on va continuer à vous
poser des questions et au fur et à
mesure vous allez nous répondre si vous
le voulez bien plutôt qu'être en
réaction à vos propos on va pas inverser
la charge
je suis là pour répondre à vos questions
donc monsieur le rapporteur
lors de
l'audition donc
il décidément pardon lors de son
audition le préfet Gravel nous a
rapporté dans son propos que vous avez
dû donc vous avez dû prendre
connaissance que il avait appris que lui
et ce ppm dans laquelle vous avez un
rôle et une fonction pourrait bénéficier
d'un
soutien
via le fond Marianne à l'issue de
l'appel téléphonique où j'ai vu avec lui
en disant que vous sortiez du cabinet de
la ministre et que vous lui aviez parlé
du fond Marianne en lui faisant
comprendre que à la fois par votre
statut votre application et votre
investissement ce que vous avez évoqué
il avait selon le dire que vous avez
que nous a rapporté le préfet Gravel
toute sa place dans le fond Marianne et
à ce moment là nous sommes en amont
évidemment de la mise en place du format
Marianne qui n'interviendra que le 20
avril
est-ce que c'est bien la réunion que
vous avez
évoqué à quel moment
est-ce que vous avez la date précise
est-ce que vous avez contacté
à ce sujet le préfet grabel et ce qu'il
vous avait d'ailleurs signifier à
quelconque engagement
certains très probable ou au contraire
très évasif
alors ce que vous a dit le préfet Gravel
est vrai mais je mettrai quelques un
bémol et quelques nuances de précision
je dois vous avouer qu'au départ la
question m'a été posée par
les inspecteurs de l'IGA honnêtement
j'avais oublié cet épisode c'est un peu
en recherchant
à la fois dans ma mémoire et essayons de
remettre la chronologie que j'ai fait
j'ai réétabli y compris par
une certaine chronologie on pense bête
un petit peu par écrit
je me suis remémoré la chose suivante la
Réunion cabinet de Madame Schiappa où
elle vient me saluer à l'issue et pas
entre deux portes ou en échange un petit
quart d'heure 10 minutes un quart
d'heure à vous d'apprécier ce qu'on peut
se dire en 10 minutes un quart d'heure
[Musique]
on me dit la chose suivante
on me dit le membre du cabinet les
membres du cabinet et ensuite madame
Schiappa me dise la chose suivante il y
a un fond un fond on me parle pas du
fond Marianne on me parle d'un fond qui
sera dédié qui va te mobilisé en me
donne pas de montant un fond important
qui sera dédié aux contre discours et
qui sera mis en place assez vite et
qu'ils attendaient les derniers
arbitrages selon votre mémoire c'est à
quelle date le 24 mars
très précisément
et donc à l'échu
enfin parce que ça m'a été dit à la fin
de la réunion
je n'ai pas réagi sur le coup
je parle de fond en parlant me parle
d'un fond voilà par l'info pour ce qui
me ce qui me fait plaisir si j'ose dire
c'est la détermination je sens une
détermination chez les politiques
c'est là où les gens sont parfois et je
compte sur vous pour prendre de la
hauteur par rapport à cette affaire
on essaie de s'y employer je veux
je vois que vous vous accordez confiance
poursuivez je vois que vous vous donnez
beaucoup de mal et je suis certain que
vous y arriverez
je me dis pas youpi je vais toucher de
l'argent enfin c'est complètement
ridicule le penser je me dis c'est super
l'État a enfin compris qu'il fallait
dégager le nerf de la guerre pour
pouvoir répondre au système je vous
rappelle je vous rappelle la chose
suivante c'est que l'islam politique
n'est pas générée par des gens
éparpillés ici et là ce ne sont pas des
individus
ce sont pas des jeunes alors cela on
sait de répondre qui sont dans les
quartiers populaires
il y a des étapes parfois derrière oui
mais ceux qui finance le discours
toxique islamiste c'est le Qatar c'est
parfois des alliés de la France c'est la
Turquie qui membre de l'OTAN pardon
pardon
le contexte monsieur le Président non il
est important de comprendre ok croyez
croyez qu'ici nous le connaissons je me
dis je me dis tout simplement qu'un fond
dédié à la contredisco est une décision
politique sur ce j'appelle
et je lui dis
mais croyant qu'il était au courant
en disant c'est une très bonne nouvelle
cette mobilisation du fond et il me dit
je ne suis pas au courant il vous dit
que vous donc il vous fait cette réponse
donc vous là vous êtes sur la même
version que les propos du préfet Gravel
qui n'ont pas été complètement confirmés
par la ministre mais ça c'est juste pour
la clarté je pense que la ministre a des
problèmes de mémoire ce qui peut arriver
c'est pour la clarté du débat moi ce que
je veux dire avant le 24 mars vous
l'avez dit vous avez eu un certain
nombre de contacts et vous aurez
l'occasion très rapidement de nous
donner les temps les modalités et donc
finalement
les échanges que vous avez pour à la
fois
nourrir le débat et les projets que vous
devez avoir en tête parce que on est au
24 mars mais très rapidement quand même
vous allez déposer un projet ambitieux
porté par une association
dont vous faites partie donc ça veut
dire que les éléments constitutifs de
votre réflexion éventuellement de votre
projet vous voyez
où vous devinez qu'elles vont devenir
qui vont devenir tangibles à travers un
projet une ambition du gouvernement dans
laquelle vous allez vous souhaiter et
vous allez vous inscrire c'est bien ça
c'est bien ça c'est à dire que je vois
que le projet qui est né à l'issue de
plusieurs
le point de départ c'est le 24 mars
avant il y a d'autres réunions mais là
il se passe quelque chose il y a une
autre réunion qui a priori se tient
début avril le 6 avril en votre présence
en votre présence pardon le préfet
Gravel est un conseiller
chargé des relations avec les élus les
collectivités
quel était à ce stade le l'objet est de
cette réunion sont contenus est-ce que
des éléments nouveaux plus précis sur le
fond un appel à projet à ce moment-là
sont abordés avec vos interlocuteurs
lors de merci monsieur le rapporteur
lors de la réunion du 6 avril on ne
parle pas de fonds on parle que du
projet on ne parle que du projet de quel
projet est-ce que celui qui sera qui
sera non parce que pardon mais le 24
mars vous dites
on vous a évoqué
l'arrivée possible d'un fond sans plus
donc je pense que le 6 avril vous allez
un peu plus loin
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
dis quel est le contenu quel est l'objet
est-ce que on vous donne plus d'éléments
non absolument pas on ne le 6 avril on
ne parle que du projet le projet que
je dois incarner à ce moment-là il y
avait besoin d'affiner un certain nombre
d'éléments encore une fois à ce moment
là je leur propose je le représente
aucun chiffrage d'accord c'est à dire
jusqu'au 24 mars je ne propose aucun
chiffre je parle d'un chiffrage
je ne propose au cas chiffrage d'accord
et le 6 avril donc on va chiffrer pardon
avec Monsieur caronagara on va chiffrer
le projet entre le 24 mars et le 6 avril
voilà d'accord non mais c'est pour ça
que je dis jusqu'au 24 mars notre projet
est un projet intellectuel une méthode
ça on est j'avais bien compris donc le 6
avril puisque le premier temps du 24
mars donc le 6 avril c'est pour ça que
je vous demandais quel est l'objet ce
que vous livrez un contenu est-ce que
vous avez des échanges vous avez une
première approche je dirais systémique
stratégique
documentée avec un projet de
financement des une ébauche d'enveloppes
je donne le d'abord le 6 avril La
Réunion porte sur
le projet en lui-même la stratégie et
pardon le jour de l'ouverture de votre
commission d'enquête j'ai vu qu'avait
fuité un document qui est dans le
dossier la fameuse fiche synthétique le
projet la subvention n'a pas été donnée
par rapport à cette fiche synthétique
c'est faux cette fiche synthétique si
ceux qui l'ont commenté avaient fait un
minimum preuve d'un minimum de
professionnalisme il aurait fallu juste
aller voir la constitution du dossier
que vous avez la constitution du dossier
le jour de l'appel à projet et dans
cette constitution de dossier figuré de
documents qu'on devait renseigner une
fiche détaillée du projet et une fiche
synthétique la fiche synthétique devait
faire un feuillet c'est-à-dire
synthétiser c'est en bon français
synthétique c'est synthétique c'est vous
qui venez avec ces éléments et ça fait
l'objet de la discussion non non moi je
viens avec un projet de d'une dizaine de
pages
et avec un bloc-notes dans lequel
j'avais noté toutes les idées etc
d'accord je vais pas vous alourdir sauf
si vous le souhaitez présente le projet
dans le détail ça prend à peu près une
heure vous présentez le projet vous vous
quittez en bons termes et sur le
chiffrage pardon sur le chiffrage je
précise une chose c'est que moi je dis
dès le départ
il n'y a absolument aucun intérêt à
financer un projet qui ne soit pas pluri
annuel et dont on n'est pas sûr de la
pérennité par conséquent à partir du 24
avril
on travaille avec Cyril caronagran
suivez comme l'a dit le président on va
rester sur le 24 mars pardon
[Musique]
pour moi entre le 24 mars et le 6 avril
nous avons travaillé avec Cyril
caronaguarra sur chiffrage
d'un projet plus réaluel au départ on
devait chiffrer 50
on va commencer à tracer ce que je vous
dis moi je suis responsable de mon
propos après vous savez dans ce genre
d'audition dans ce genre d'exercice des
gens peuvent oublier être imprécis etc
je vous le redis encore une fois nous
avons travaillé sur le chiffrage d'un
projet plus réannuel et nous avons
établi ensemble c'est lui qui a fait
enfin qui a renseigné des éléments
techniques c'est-à-dire le bilan
prévisionnel sur trois ans
et le chiffrage complet sur trois ans
montrez que le projet sur trois années
coûte aller coûter un million 500000
euros pourquoi un million 500.000 euros
ça peut faire hurler parce que tout
simplement la riposte sur Internet
nécessite la mobilisation de moyens
humains qui dit moyen humain dit moyen
humain passez-moi l'expression seniors
c'est à dire des gens confirmés c'est
pas avec des juniors ou des débutants
qu'on peut faire la riposte à
l'islamisme par conséquent il faut des
salaires qui disent salaires donc on
avait imaginé une petite armada de
personnes capable de répondre sur
internet si vous raison pour laquelle si
vous voulez bien attendre
sur trois ans pour une précision le
ce document je l'ai sur trois ans
il était question
une première année
je pense qu'on va à 635000 euros
par contre donc nous sommes le 6 avril
vous avez donc vous venez avec votre
projet vous quittez je pense en bon
terme et j'imagine qu'on vous dit
quelque chose on me dit on va étudier le
projet on est en train d'étudier le
projet
très sérieusement alors attendez et
quand j'ai besoin parce que je veux le
mot projet il peut pas être utilisé dans
tous les sens donc vous sortez vous
quittez forcément je le devine en bons
termes et on vous dit quoi ben écoutez
on va regarder maintenant on va prendre
votre dossier et regarder comment il
s'inscrit dans la durée on va étudier
votre projet un projet monsieur le
rapporteur vous allez projeter
vous allez comprendre pourquoi
j'essaie d'être méthodique donc vous
sortez alors il s'avère donc le
lendemain
est évoqué l'idée d'un appel à projet à
l'initiative du Gouvernement sur lequel
le gouvernement réfléchit donc je
conclus de ce que vous venez de me dire
que le 6 avril veille du 7
ou sera évoqué l'idée d'un appel à
projet vous n'avez eu aucune information
d'un d'une possible démarche
initié par le gouvernement de lancer un
appel à projet sur cette thématique
absolument pas d'accord absolument pas
je n'ai aucune information le laissant
croire que le gouvernement allait faire
un appel au projet d'accord donc à ce
stade monsieur le rapporteur si vous
permettez à ce stade
le 6 avril je parle au nom d'une
association
le Parlement d'une association qui porte
un projet validé politiquement
et qui est en train de discuter avec des
pouvoirs publics quant à sa réalisation
nous l'avons ni appel à projet je suis
pas au courant encore et le projet
puisqu'il est porté me dites-vous par
une association j'imagine qu'il a fait
l'objet de débat avec les membres de
l'association le bureau et qui a un
compte rendu de validation de ce projet
qui va être peut-être soutenu par le
gouvernement moi j'ai tenu au courant
les différents les quelques membres
qu'il y a dans l'association et nous
avons
formalisme ou avec du formalisme il y a
eu un formalisme mais qui est
un conseil d'administration d'accord
avec un compte rendu conseil
d'administration
il vous semble vous êtes sûrs
du projet à partir du mois de janvier et
donc le 6 je finis cette ce rendez-vous
le 7 je reçois un email du conseiller 3
et le conseiller 3
m'envoie une série de documents
me disant au sujet de votre projet
merci de renseigner l'ensemble de ces
documents et les transmettre aussi ipdr
sur ce et vous avez 48 heures pour le
faire s'il vous plaît alors j'y viens
tout de suite ou vous voyez il y a une
bonne articulation donc
deux questions sur le travail avec le
cpdr et son secrétaire général à
plusieurs reprises il a été évoqué que
vous étiez d'ailleurs formateur
au sein et vous l'avez
sous-entendu voir dit assez clairement
au sein de l'unité de ce que le
gouvernement appelle le contre discours
républicain vous me dire nous dire qui
vous a sollicité pour réaliser ces
formations et à partir de quand
les avez-vous dispensés
étiez-vous d'ailleurs rémunéré soit
personnellement soit au titre d'une
structure d'entreprise ou
associative jusque jusqu'à quelle
période avez-vous dispensé ces
formations et est-ce que avec le cpdr
vous avez d'autres actions
voire même d'autres actions ayant donné
lieu à des rémunérations bon on va
revenir un peu quelques quelques mois en
arrière donc on est en avril on revient
en octobre
lorsque Monsieur Gravel est nommé
au cipdr je vous l'ai dit j'étais déjà
en contact avec son son
prédécesseur j'avais aussi quelques
contacts au sein du cpdr je suis grave
elle m'appelle avec d'autres et nous
propose de constituer un comité
scientifique première étape et
de ce que je me souviens il me dit j'ai
besoin du soutien de tout le monde parce
que je suis chargé de mettre en place
très vite une unité de contrôle de
contrediscours républicain et je n'ai
pas les moyens humains suffisants en
tout cas de la ressource qui maîtrise la
matière
lors de discussions soit en groupe avec
les autres personnes sollicitées soit en
bilatérale il m'a demandé s'il pouvait
compter sur mon aide je parle en une
première étape sur mon aide je lui ai
assuré qu'il pouvait compter sur mon
aide entre le 2 octobre le jour de soul
le lendemain de sa nomination jusqu'à
novembre j'ai agi de façon bénévole
auprès du cpdr au quotidien
au quotidien
le 24 ou le 25 octobre il m'a appelé
pour me dire que la ministre délégué à
la citoyenneté et lui-même souhaité que
je prenne par un voyage officiel
déplacement officiel dans le Tarn à Albi
pour participer à un séminaire ce qu'on
appelle les clients
donc le 26 octobre nous sommes rendus
madame Schiappa Tristan Gravel et
moi-même Albi pour assurer cette journée
de séminaire et ensuite madame Schiappa
que vous avez c'est peut-être un détail
vous avez voyagé ensemble non moi vous
savez je suis en train j'ai mes
contraintes que j'ai citées de façon
rapide en introduction donc je voyage
dans des conditions qui sont gérées par
le ministère de l'Intérieur et selon
je comprends bien les contrats en
question donc
le lendemain nous avons tous les trois
participer à cette journée de séminaire
et Madame Schiappa poursuivi sa visite
ministérielle et on nous sommes nous
sommes rentrés et j'ai continué mes
relations avec le cpdr on a entamé un
début je dirais d'échanges intellectuels
et encore une fois c'est sol était
quotidienne
et je ne m'en plains pas c'était j'étais
j'étais totalement je dirais disposer
vers la mi-novembre Christian Gravel m'a
fait savoir qu'il était gêné par le fait
de me solliciter au quotidien et qui
comptait sur mon application et que je
serai de toute façon rémunérée et qu'il
a eu l'accord de la ministre d'accord et
ça donc cela a fait l'objet d'un devis
et d'une facture en bonne et due forme
qui qui était me semble-t-il parce que
je sache maintenant après il faut voir
comment fonctionne cette administration
et comment fonctionne ce gouvernement on
n'a pas fait ça je vous le rassure ou
sous-sol d'un café dans le 20e
arrondissement on a fait ça dans des
ministères en bonne et due forme avec
des sociétés qui existent des factures
des
institutions régaliennes pardon il faut
le dire toutes les institutions
régaliennes a commencé par la présidence
de la République a commencé par le
ministre ministère le cabinet du
ministre de l'Intérieur a commencé par
la le cabinet de Madame Schiappa savait
que j'étais totalement impliqué que je
reconnais les équipes de Lucie donc vous
avez commencé à bénéficier de
rémunération à partir de la le devis a
été établi fin octobre
et
ça a été fait en nom propre au nom d'une
association ou d'une entreprise d'accord
merci juste ça couvrait quelle période
ça couvrait alors c'était un forfait et
ce forfait payable en une fois qui
devait durer initialement une année je
l'ai fait durer jusqu'au jusqu'à janvier
janvier 2023
c'est un forfait mais qui a été payé en
plusieurs fois puisque c'était une
action à venir une fois c'est un forfait
payé en une fois oui mais pas comment ça
se passe plusieurs mois
généralement quand vous délivrer une
facture à l'administration au mois de
mois de novembre décembre vous êtes payé
3 4 5 mois plus tard de mémoire donc si
vous on est preneur de je dirais de la
trace de ce document si vous voulez bien
verrez avec la police judiciaire
d'accord tout est à son niveau je voilà
merci je voulais juste m'assurer je mon
esprit
non pas embrumé mais un peu confus le 24
mars la réunion se tient
en votre présence et en présence de
membres du cabinet
et du préfet Gravel où le préfet Gravel
24 mars il n'était pas il était il était
de 6 avril sinon je l'aurais pas appelé
après pour lui dire que je sors du
cabinet d'accord
dernière sur le les contacts avec le
cpdr et son secrétaire général quand
avez-vous discuté pour la première fois
avec les membres enfin le secrétaire
général plutôt du projet de l'essai ppm
parce que vous avez bien parlé de votre
projet que j'appellerai dans l'idée dans
la stratégie et comme les jours chaque
jour compte
le 9 avril Cyril karunagaran envoie le
le projet chiffré aussi PDR à la demande
du cabinet
à partir de là pour une question
d'organisation et pour tout vous dire
moi je n'aime pas c'est pas je suis pas
très attiré par les questions
administratives et la gestion de ces
aspects là donc on sait reparti les
rôles de façon très claire c'est que
Cyril devait garder d'être
l'interlocuteur du cpdr et moi je devais
il a plutôt une formation très
à l'aise sur les questions
administratives il est très allé sur les
questions administratives voilà pour
tout vous dire il nous a pas vraiment
dit qu'il était parfaitement à l'aise
sur les sujets administratifs et
financiers mais
comme vous formez aussi un binôme assez
proche je voulais juste vous dire qu'il
y a pas de j'ai pas de sujet j'ai pas
compris j'ai pas compris votre remarque
j'ai pas entendu je pense que vous
l'avez compris je vais vous la reformer
la même manière mais pourquoi vous
préjugés
dans un échange cordial pourquoi vous
vous matrez quelque chose
cordiale et courtois je reste donc
cordial et courtois mais par honnêteté
parce que moi je n'aime pas les choses
trap et que je préfère
s'il y a un point de désaccord on
l'identifie madame la ministre hier m'a
fait répéter deux fois la même question
et même la deuxième fois elle m'a
expliqué qu'elle ne comprenait pas soit
j'ai un langage abscon mais en général
on dit je suis plutôt assez direct voilà
c'est tout mais je vous dis que le
Président nous a déclaré ne pas être
habitué à
[Musique]
pour finalement porter le projet de fond
Marianne puisque c'était pas à ma
connaissance vraiment l'objet de ces
associations quel lien il y avait vous
trouvez
quels étaient d'ailleurs jusqu'à ce
moment-là les objectifs
portés par cette association je vous
remercie quand
la discussion a lieu au cabinet
au départ je ne c'est vrai que j'informe
Cyril très tôt
je crois de même des descentes
mais dans mon esprit c'est pas acté je
veux dire c'est pas acté que ça soit
l'usuppm qui qui va porter le projet
je laisse le choix au membre du cabinet
je leur dis je suis en contact avec
plusieurs associations je leur cite
quatre ou cinq associations
et je cite lui seppm dans sa
dénomination complète
l'Union des fédérations des sociétés
d'éducation physique et de préparation
au service militaire ça fait sourire
tout le monde
il demande qu'est-ce que c'est que ça je
dis c'est une vieille association de sa
domination 1885 sa naissance et elle est
reconnue d'utilité publique
tout le monde s'est arrêté sur cette
reconnaissance d'utilité publique ah bon
allez reconnaître l'utilité publique je
dis oui
et j'y suis depuis quelques temps
ils me disent très bien on va voir et on
vous dit voilà mais ça serait une bonne
idée qu'est-ce qu'elle fait je dis elle
fait ça donc j'explique un peu son
historique et j'explique que depuis 2016
2017 il y a eu au sein de l'association
et une réorientation sur les questions
de prévention la radicalisation j'ai
entendu des commentaires en disant oui
mais c'est pas l'objet etc lorsque cette
association est née à la fin du 19e
siècle et que ces statues ont été
réactualisées je crois début du 20e
reconnaissance d'utilité publique depuis
on est dans un contexte historique
d'aucun connaissent on parle d'armée la
jeunesse
physiquement c'est à dire c'était une
association qui préparait les enfants
des petits bourgeois à aller à la guerre
bon
je pense que si on devait dire
aujourd'hui qu'il faut réarmer la
société intellectuellement et réarmée et
armée la jeunesse pour qu'elle fasse
face pour qu'elle fasse
face qu'elle fasse je dirais barrage
intellectuellement
et qu'elle devienne hermétique à la
propagande islamiste ce n'est pas
contradictoire donc après on peut avoir
une discussion mais cette discussion
pardon je vais vous le dire je vais pas
l'avoir ici en ce qui me concerneaux
lorsque c'est un débat juridique c'est
tout c'est un débat juridique de toutes
les lois c'est toutes les associations
sous la loi 1901 juste s'il vous plaît
voilà donc 2016-2017 vous venez de dire
vous
réorientez puisque vous êtes je
comprends à ce moment-là déjà membre de
l'association à ce moment-là vous
modifiez l'objet de
les activités de l'association
puisqu'elle est reconnue d'utiliser
public il y a là aussi des modifications
des comptes-rendus qui en attestent oui
non oui on en a parlé je sais que il y a
des comptes rendus et des assemblées
générales qui ont évité le sujet je sais
que Cyril lorsqu'il a pris la présidence
je dirais traiter ce sujet c'est à quel
moment qu'il 2016-2017 le problème qui
s'est posé c'est que toutes 2016-2017
je vous dis 2016-2017 si j'avais si je
savais que c'était le 24 octobre 2016
vous l'aurais dit mais c'est 2016-2017
je reprends l'expression exacte qui a
été utilisé par des avocats c'est ouvrir
une usine à gaz que d'essayer de refaire
les statuts d'une association qui est
déjà reconnue d'utilité publique
c'est-à-dire que ils ont expliqué que
vous perdez la reconnaissance d'utilité
publique et que c'est très compliqué etc
etc bon d'accord je suis pas là pour le
coup spécialiste des questions
administratives sur
sur les associations
alors dans les documents dont on dispose
il est indiqué que vous êtes
salarié de l'uspm dans le cadre de la
réalisation du projet du fond Marianne
premièrement y a-t-il une compatibilité
juridique entre cette situation de
salarié et les statuts de l'association
puisque vous avez également et je le
signale indiqué au secrétaire général du
cpdr que vous alliez démissionner du
conseil administration l'avez-vous fait
si vous l'avez fait ça s'est matérialisé
de quelle manière et à quelle date
j'avais entre l'année 2020 et le début
de l'année 2021 j'étais très oreiller
j'ai démissionné du poste de trésorier
des février donc 2020 il faudra qu'on
regarde la date à partir du moment où
vous êtes trésorier vous devenez salarié
absolument pas non mais c'est d'accord
jusqu'au 24 avril jusqu'au 24 mai 2021
pour le compte du projet
ilaique je n'avais jamais été salarié ni
je me suis fait rembourser ni j'ai y
compris sur des frais que j'ai engagé
pour le compte de l'usu super jamais
la question de la rémunération est lié
au fait que je devais m'impliquer
complètement dans le projet que je
devais laisser un certain nombre
d'activités et pardon laissez-moi
sourire un petit peu aussi là aussi
c'est que le côté ridicule quelques mois
auparavant je lance un projet personnel
à haut potentiel financé financier
d'accord qui n'a besoin du soutien de
personnes avec un partenaire
suffisamment solide je le mets entre
parenthèses pour aller faire un signé un
pathétique contrat à 4422 euros brut
pour toucher au final autour de 3200
euros net donc net imposable donc à un
moment donné le ridicule il faut pas
qu'il tue j'ai 35 ans de vie
professionnelle 56 ans je ne pense pas
qu'il soit scandaleux que je sois
rémunéré à cette hauteur maintenant sur
la compatibilité entre la rémunération
et le statut d'administrateur puisque
des journalistes peu informer mal
informés qui se prennent pour des
travailler des et qui supplantes
intellectuellement la connaissance que
peuvent avoir des avocats spécialisés
dans le droit du travail il aurait fallu
juste consulter peut-être un spécialiste
du droit du travail et leur expliquer la
chose suivante c'est que la rémunération
d'un administrateur est possible
lorsqu'il s'agit de rémunérer une
mission spécifique et non pas sa
fonction d'administrateur ce qui est ce
qui était mon cas donc il n'y a
absolument très aucune contradiction
j'avais demandé à Cyril si je devais
totalement démissionner de l'association
il m'a dit que non m'a dit que non et
par conséquent je suis resté
administrateur et j'ai accepté de
remplir dans le cadre d'un contrat de
travail qui a été signé en bonne et due
forme d'accord donc puisque vous parlez
des administrateurs dans la liste de
ceci
qui nous a été communiqué dans le
dossier de candidature en fait
la liste des administrateurs ne
correspondait pas à la liste qui était
enregistrée en préfecture est-ce que
vous en aviez est-ce que vous avez
connaissance de divergence non d'accord
je l'ai appris que récemment
quand est-ce que vous avez évoqué pour
la première fois l'US oppm votre
association
auprès
des autorités auxquelles vous aviez à
faire c'est à dire soit le cabinet de la
ministre soit le secrétariat général
le cap j'ai évoqué le j'ai évoqué je
n'avais jamais évoqué le nom de
l'association à Christian Gravel j'ai
évoqué le nom de l'association avec le
cabinet et à l'issue je crois que je
l'ai évoqué à deux reprises une fois en
mars
mais début mars
dans une rencontre informelle qui
n'était pas dans le cadre des des autres
rencontres j'avais dit que j'étais voilà
lié à mais je l'ai dit à un des
conseillers mais là où j'en ai parlé
avec précision c'est lors de la réunion
du 6 avril
par la suite Christian Gravel a
découvert me semble-t-il encore une fois
l'existence de l'UEF lorsque l'uspm a
envoyé le dossier de candidature
le 9 le 9 avril au soir en fin
d'après-midi
et je précise lorsqu'on nous a envoyé le
lorsqu'on m'a envoyé lorsqu'un un des
conseillers
conseiller 3 m'a envoyé le mail avec les
documents renseignés il m'a bien
expliqué qu'il avait que nous avions
deux jours pour enseigner le et que il
fallait absolument que le dossier soit
envoyé au plus tard vendredi en fin
d'après-midi
ceci fait oui
vous nous avez un peu déjà répondu à la
question
un moment donné dans les discussions
on en arrive finalement à dire il faut
présenter un dossier vous encourage à
présenter un dossier vous proposez un
dossier et un moment donné vous avez une
discussion sur l'association et vous
nous dites
vous avez proposé trois quatre
structures d'associatives
potentiellement pouvant faire c'est ce
que vous avez dit on est bien d'accord
donc ça veut dire de manière très simple
que à un moment donné le cabinet vous
dit vous ne pouvez pas prendre l'action
j'allais dire en non personnel bon ça
aurait pu s'imaginer contractuellement
bon mais on souhaite en fait non pas
travailler avec l'association on en
connaît aucune des quatre c'est pas le
sujet c'est on veut travailler avec vous
et donc l'association servira à porter
apporter l'action quel que soit ses
éventuels compétences
donc c'est ça le sujet le sujet c'est
que l'appel à candidature qui va venir
derrière même si on veut le présente pas
encore
c'est un appel en tout cas vers des
structures et donc il faut que ce sont
des associations qui répondent et c'est
pour cela que vous répondez avec le on
est d'accord on est absolument d'accord
avec une précision sur les quatre
associations que je cite 3 était
totalement connu du cabinet
ah pardon et donc refuser pas refuser
la seule qui connaissait pas je dis
certaines façons c'est pour ça que je me
sens trahi aujourd'hui je me sens trahi
par les mensonges je me sens trahi par
les approximations et je me sens trahi
par la politique de l'amnésie qui est
mené dans ce dossier
encore une fois je rappelle je n'ai pas
sollicité de subventions on m'a
sollicité je rappelle que l'association
j'ai cité plusieurs associations je les
ai laissés choisir l'association pour
les amener dans une logique de
coopération on est on est censé être
comme on pourrait pas permettre moi
l'expression dans un même bateau donc on
est en confiance avec qui il
souhaitez-vous que je travaille que je
mette en application ce projet il y a je
connais un tel je connais un tel je
connais un tel non non un tel celui-là
non c'est quoi ça ça c'est voilà et ça
s'est passé comme ça ça c'est pas passé
autrement ça s'est passé comme ça toute
une autre toute autre récit et mensonger
je le dis
que celui-ci d'autres non la question
qui était posée c'est pourquoi cette
association vous donnez la réponse voilà
je pense que des fois mais il faut pas
voir du mal partout
on est d'accord bien
d'ailleurs le préfet Gravel lorsqu'il a
il a dit les choses il a déclaré au
sujet de cette subvention qu'elle payait
de l'intelligence
c'était
comment dire une expression très
favorable à votre endroit elle payait de
l'intelligence je pense pas qu'il est
dit dans ce dans cet esprit pardon
monsieur le Président il a dit c'est en
fait non je vais continuer vous allez
voir une œuvre de l'esprit que ce soit
dans cette association une autre on
produit de l'intellect et je continue et
d'abord de la production intellectuelle
donc pas laisser finir ma phrase donc
c'est de la production intellectuelle et
une des questions qui vient derrière
c'était donc est-ce que cette subvention
a constitué en quelque sorte un levier
de financement pour un travail de
consultant alors
si cette question a été posée ainsi
c'est parce qu'on n'avait pas d'abord
l'information que vous venez vous donner
que par ailleurs les activités que vous
meniez sur demande quotidienne avez-vous
dit du cipdr était elle-même déjà
rémunéré par un contrat de consultant
enfin cette partie en fait le contrat en
question le
devis qui a été
élaboré
prévoit un travail de consulting
prévoir en français de consultants de
consultant à prévoir un travail de
formation et prévoir un travail de d'une
certaine façon de proposition
proposition de compte de contenu
donc et ça ça a duré entre
je dirais les mois d'octobre jusqu'au
mois de mars à peu près l'ensemble après
on s'est attelé uniquement sur la partie
formation ok peu importe peu importe
vous nous dites vous nous avez dit que
jusqu'en janvier 2023 elle vous aviez un
contrat de consultant que ce soit de la
formation que ce soit autre chose etc et
dans le cadre je vais le formuler donc
du coup la question
vous sentez bien quand même qu'il y
avait un lien forcément parce que je
veux dire travailler aller Albi etc tout
ça ça a des coûts bon voilà toute
rigueur ça a des coups bon donc il y
avait bien quelque chose de cette nature
et puis imaginer que le contrat que vous
passez avec l'association couvrait cette
activité Consulting vous avez dit
préalablement à la question non
l'activité de consultant elle est
jusqu'en janvier 2023
financé par un contrat propre alors du
coup ça amène à une deuxième question
que vous voyez arriver vous dans le le
nouveau contrat avec cette association
vous avez donc une rémunération qui est
qualifiée de rémunération à temps plein
rémunération à temps plein et en même
temps vous avez un contrat de consultant
pour la même période
dans l'ubiquité capacité à faire
plusieurs choses à la fois
comment vous faites là vous avez à la
fois un 35 heures qui n'est pas
d'ailleurs décrit comme un 35 heures
mais comme comment dire une action
permanente
avec
l'association et en même temps contrat
de consultants qui portent sur certains
aspects particuliers si je puis dire en
formation etc avec le CPL est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer comment on
peut avoir la juxtaposition de ces deux
contrats
ceux qui ont travaillé avec moi à
différentes époques
vont comprendre ce que je vais vous dire
j'ai une capacité de travail qui est
bien supérieure
à la normale
par passion par
je dirais intérêt intellectuel pour la
matière
et une époque où je réalisais des
reportages et j'écrivais des articles
tout en rédigeant mes livres le soir
donc je suis quelqu'un qui travaille
énormément
je n'ai je veux pas ouvrir une autre
polémique politique je n'ai jamais cru
que des gens de mon profil puissent se
suffire d'être 35 heures donc je
travaille pas 35 heures je travaille pas
40 je travaille beaucoup plus mais
weekend sont très rares bien et sont
plutôt je vous rassure nous aussi non ce
que ça rassure surtout ce qui vous ont
élu j'espère bien restons sur la
question mais restons sur la question et
surtout voyez-vous sous l'angle de
l'administration on est toujours
là-dedans bon vous avez vous vous avez
deux contrats en même temps financés par
le même organisme le cipdr
qui nous a pas parlé d'ailleurs
du contrat consultant faut dire qu'on
l'aura pas posé la question parce que
elle t'es pas directement dans le fond
Marianne mais du coup quand même ça ça
pose question sur le fait d'accepter
de mettre en place un contrat avec une
association comprenant un salarié à
temps plein indiquer comme tel et
d'ailleurs sur les feuilles de salaire
indiquées comme tel et en même temps un
contrat dont je ne pourrais pas le
montant et c'est pas le sujet le sujet
je peux vous le dire
39 500 euros hors taxes
le quoi par quoi le contrat global sur
l'année sur un an sur deux ans
deux ans de
octobre à janvier de
novembre 2000 20 jusqu'à janvier 23 donc
ça fait pas deux ans
un an et trois mois même
novembre
2023 merci j'étais à 2022 excusez-moi
quasiment d'accord 30 mois c'est 3900
euros hors taxes voilà
de novembre à novembre de novembre à
novembre deux fois c'est 24 mois
décembre janvier de 24 26 mois ce qu'on
voit très précisément ça c'est une
information nouvelle
si vous voulez elle pose pas de problème
par rapport à vous pose un problème à
moi rien ne me pose problème évidemment
et puis c'est pas le sujet sujet c'est
en constat et vous avez j'allais dire
une même structure qui vous finance en
parallèle
sur deux montants différents pour des
actions supplémentaires alors que vous
avez d'un côté un contrat à temps plein
bien on le note nous on l'avait
interrogé plutôt dans l'autre sens au
départ de connaissons pas ce contrat en
disant est-ce que ça couvre pas
finalement une activité de consultant
parce qu'on sentait bien que cette
activité consultant existait vous nous
l'avez confirmé elle existe mais elle a
été traitée à part du fond Marianne
c'est ce que vous nous dites très bien
alors
on revient
on revient sur un donc le sujet là aussi
qui pose une difficulté
non pas par rapport à l'association en
tant que telle mais à la manœuvre en
tant que telle de l'administration qui
est en fait il y a eu des trucs
clairement et puis on l'a bien compris
il y a eu des négociations préalables en
réalité sur cette action
spécifique il y a peu d'acteurs qui sont
en capacité de faire vous sollicite vous
déposez un dossier et ce dossier il est
déposé tout simplement avant même que le
fond Marianne ne soit créé voilà ça
c'est l'effet mais j'allais dire que
de ce point de vue là
le sujet porte plutôt sur la façon dont
l'administration fait les choses voilà
hein bien d'accord mais on veut bien le
on le spécifique bien et d'autre part le
comité de programmation dans lui il
arrive le 13 avril 2021 avant même la
question du fond Marianne en tant que
comité de sélection donc le dossier est
déposé avant même donc et il va être
fléché sur le fond de Marianne après
coup bien entendu donc tout ça est assez
clair
qui a répondu à l'appel à projet bon sur
la partie
constitution intellectuelle du programme
il n'y a pas de doute nous avons devant
nous le bon interlocuteur de
l'association c'est vous qui avez
consult le projet
est-ce que d'autres ont pris part à la
rédaction monsieur caronagarran est-ce
que sur la prestation intellectuelle de
conception du projet est-ce qu'il y a
été également associé où est-ce que lui
était plutôt sur la pratique purement
chiffrée non non il a participé et pas
que lui
une personne que je qualifierais de
rédacteur 1 il y en a eu deux rédacteurs
rédacteurs 1 à participer également
comprendrez encore une fois que je ne
jetterai pas en pâture les noms donc
rédacteur 1 à participer cyril caronaga
a participé et moi-même donc
je parle de rédacteur a de façon
anticipée la personne avec laquelle une
des personnes avec laquelle j'avais
pensé intellectuellement de projet et
qui va qui aller nous rejoindre quelques
mois plus tard comme salarié je l'ai
associé à la réflexion et évidemment
nous avons conçu ensemble à trois dans
une logique comme on dit communément de
ping-pong peut-être même à 4 puisque il
y a rédacteur ou rédactrice a et donc
j'imagine qu'il y a un rédacteur 2 dans
le rédacteur 2 est venu après il n'a pas
travaillé sur n'a pas travaillé sur le
projet directement il a travaillé sur
d'autres aspects mais pas sur le projet
tel qu'il a été présenté en avril
d'accord
et quelles sont donc les pièces
puisqu'il y a eu il y a un débat vous
êtes un peu venu tout à l'heure sur les
pièces qui ont été envoyées à ce moment
là
donc le dossier tel que il comprend quoi
je peux vous retrouver l'e-mail exact
mais outre le CERFA
il y a quatre de mémoire 4 documents
trois ou quatre documents qui sont
demandés je sais pas et vous êtes sur un
montant de 650000 euros c'est celui-là
on est sur 35000 ah non non pas du tout
on est sur un montant
de
une demande de de subventions à financer
à 100%
pour une première année à 635600 c'est
ce que je viens de vous dire 635000
euros
voilà donc on est bien d'accord alors ce
dossier arrive il arrive donc d'ailleurs
directement
chez le préfet Ravel
par mail notamment chez le préfet de
Ravel et ensuite comment comment
finalement se déroule
le débat entre finalement cette
réception de premier dossier si je puis
dire
à un moment donné on vous demande de
revoir
sa présentation son montant comment ça
comment ça se passe
euh dans dans cette première phase après
réception du dossier de 635000 25 pardon
avec une première année 635000 alors ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure dès le
moment où le 9 avril Cyril caronagran
envoie aussi PDR cette demande de
subvention telle que validés
politiquesment par le cabinet de Madame
Schiappa je laisse Cyril caronagaran
traité avec ses interlocuteurs aussi PDR
nous n'allons plus avoir de aucune
nouvelle
et moi j'apprends par voie de presse
à travers une interview de la ministre
qu'il y a un appel à projet
appelé fond Marianne qui est mis en
place donc autour du 20 21 avril
quelques jours plus tard je crois 4-5
jours plus tard Cyril car on a garant
désolé je ne sais pas s'il m'a contacté
par email ou par téléphone me dit qu'il
a reçu une communication du cpdr
l'invitant
à reformuler la candidature du 9 avril
en l'intégrant en répondant au projet
appelé son mariage
pour moi
je trouve rien à redire si tu une
question de d'habillage administratif
à ce stade il y a rien qui me choque
j'aurais dû peut-être être un peu plus
vigilant parce qu'à partir de là on va
rentrer dans un processus tout à l'heure
j'ai utilisé un mot lourd j'estime avoir
été piégé j'estime avoir été
instrumentalisée j'espère qu'ils l'ont
fait inconsciemment j'espère qu'ils
l'ont fait inconsciemment et
involontairement mais j'ai été
instrumentalisé et j'ai été trahi et je
pèse mes mots et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi parce que lorsque nous
discutons au sein du cabinet je dis bien
trois choses première des choses je
n'accepterai jamais de m'engager dans
une opération ponctuelle d'une année ah
il faut que ça soit plus rien annuel
2 je ne vais pas aller
en quête de subvention je ne sais pas le
faire et l'association qui a été
désignée pour porter le projet ne s'est
pas le faire non plus il n'a pas
l'habitude de faire donc je sollicite en
suivant une subvention 100%
troisièmement
pour que le projet soit réalisé
puisqu'il a été
[Musique]
première étape Cyril caronagara reçoit
donc cet email pour lui dire de
reformuler de sa demande dans le cadre
de l'appel à projet le fond Marianne
et candidate pour le compte de l'US oppm
dans le cas du fond Marianne
quelques jours plus tard il envoie donc
un deuxième projet pour le compte du
fond Marianne et l'explicite l'ensemble
du projet où là il y a un CERFA d'un
million
50000 euros sur trois ans
avec
une première année publiée dans la
préparation de ce CERFA il a des
échanges et surtout par mail que j'ai vu
sur ces sur ces échanges il commence par
lui dire nous allons nous allons
financer que 60% de la première année
bon il fait donc ce deuxième CERFA qu'il
envoie en mai
et à partir
pardonner mon imprécision les 22 ou 23
mai
j'apprends d'abord par mes sources
personnelles que la candidature allait
probablement très même très probablement
être retenu et j'apprends par Cyril
carnagarran 4 jours ou cinq jours plus
tard qu'il a reçu un mail en lui disant
que le projet allait très probablement
en tout cas avait toute cette toutes ces
chances d'être retenu nous sommes mis
immédiatement au travail
il se trouve que on s'est mis au travail
parce que je suis en confiance etc et
donc
on m'apprend que finalement c'est 350
000 350 000 euros pour l'année 2021 que
ça ne correspond qu'il pouvait pas
financer l'administration on peut pas
financer plus de 60% et qui nous
appartenait d'aller chercher des
subventions ailleurs bon
j'ai fait contre
passez-moi l'expression maladroite
je vais le contexte contre mauvaise
fortune bon coeur c'est à dire que je
m'étais engagé j'ai commencé à m'engager
auprès des gens j'ai commencé à mettre
élaborer le projet etc et la
progressivement le projet se dénaturer
par son soutien financier et se vider de
sa substance de fait et on arrive au
final à des allers-retours incessants
après même la notification entre Cyril
car on a garant et l'administration qui
va lui demander de les dernières
modifications avant la signature de la
convention fin juillet 2021 c'est-à-dire
près de deux mois et demi voire près de
trois mois après trois mois après la
notification alors après la
multiplication alors que les contrats
travaillent après parce que voilà
d'accord on va rester là d'abord
pouvez-vous nous dire
comment donc alors c'est dans ces
discussions donc vous dites que vous
vous n'y participez pas
que finalement pas de 635 000 a d'abord
un montant de 300 000 au milieu nous
sommes d'accord quel montant de 300000
il y a eu un moment donné une
mais un fléchage de 300000 après le
comité le premier comité
très attribution du 13 avril donc vous
n'êtes pas informé de cela je suis pas
formé et vous n'avez pas participé
ensuite à une
discussion quelconque entre ce moment-là
c'est-à-dire le mois d'avril et le
comité de sélection qui affiche un
montant de
355 355
000 donc il y a une remontée
parfaitement je dirais sur la même
posture ou explication que la ministre
c'est à dire que vous êtes
concerné par le projet mais vous
finalement vous tenez à distance pour
qu'il n'y ait je dirais pas de souci
ça c'est une accusation à non vous
donnez vous demande je ne vous permettra
je le précise rien du tout vous allez
retirer tout de suite ce que vous voulez
dire chez moi vous entendez il y a
aucune posture je suis pas un homme
politique votre déclaration vous retirez
tout de suite je n'ai rien de comparable
avec Madame c'est clair rien de
compliqué rien de la même manière que
j'ai fait observer hier à madame la
ministre
sur la question de l'équité et de la
transparence elle est utilisée les mêmes
mots que l'inspection générale de
l'administrations
je suis dans aucune posture monsieur je
vous réponds sincérité et avec honnêteté
transparence et bien arrêté arrêtez de
me lancer à la figure des choses rien à
la figure j'ai le droit de formuler de
reformuler comme j'ai fait tout à
l'heure pour être sûr d'avoir bien
compris donc vous venez de nous donner
des éléments vous avez été convié on va
poursuivre à une réunion avec notamment
le directeur de cabinet de Madame
Schiappa et le secrétaire général du
cpdr le 22 avril 2021
pouvez-vous nous décrire le déroulement
de cette réunion et est-ce qu'à ce
moment-là le niveau de la subvention a
été évoquée clairement un montant
non monsieur le rapporteur finalement
donc il y a une seconde
demande de combien de leur rappeler on a
déjà parlé de
355000 euros qui est adressé pouvez-vous
nous indiquer les raisons qui ont
conduit l'uspm a déposé un deuxième
montant avec un montant donc rehaussée
de subventions même si j'ai entendu vous
nous avez vous nous avez dit à quelques
instants que le 300 000 vous en aviez
entendu parler pour le coup si
j'interprète
par les médias mais vous n'avez jamais
puisque la demande initiale était de 635
000 vous vous n'avez jamais eu
connaissance d'une proposition à 300 000
d'abord voler votre lecture est fausse
parce que je ne dirige pas un cabinet
fausse parce que Cyril karunagaran
administrativement il n'est pas sur mes
ordres c'est plutôt le contraire vous
avez une lecture fausse parce que vous
m'attribuez une sorte de non non non je
ne peux pas vous laisser dire ce que
vous avez dit
le directeur vous n'êtes pas là pour
Monsieur on est là pour avoir
vous faites
vous faites un raccourci non je pose des
questions un raccourci je ne sais pas
pourquoi je ne suis pas dragon
je vous le dis vous faites un raccourci
malheureux vous ne comparez à Madame
Schiappa je n'ai absolument rien
absolument pas ce que j'ai dit sur le
fond ni sur la forme c'est clair c'est
mais j'ai d'abord vous n'avez pas de ni
d'ordre ni je vous demande d'aller
excusez-moi je pense que vous devez
garder et vos nerfs et votre maîtrise
nous essayons de le faire et poursuivons
et je vous le dis je suis quelqu'un vous
savez je suis quelqu'un d'assez entier
je respecte les institutions et je
respecte les gens qui me respectent mais
j'ai le moment où on me respecte plus je
vais aller sur un autre temps je vous le
dis tout de suite
mais
je n'ai jamais changé de trajectoire et
vous pourrez regarder au long des
auditions j'essaie d'ailleurs d'être
assez constant certains disent même que
c'est bien ils apprécient cette forme de
sérénité voilà je vous dis
alors regardons la sérénité c'est pour
c'est pour l'honneur de l'institution
que vous représentez c'est pour la terre
de tout le monde c'est pour l'honneur de
l'institution et au-dessus de vous donc
c'est pour l'honneur de la situation
s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît vous aussi s'il vous
plaît il n'y a pas d'accusation à porter
comme vous le redis voilà revenons
peut-être permet revenons sur cette
réunion du 22 avril il y a eu une
réunion le 22 avril et la question
est-ce que vous étiez bien cette réunion
le 22 avril ce n'est pas une réunion le
22 Avril c'est une invitation que je
reçois pour
être reçu par Madame Marlène Schiappa
ce que je vous ai dit ce que vous avez
dit c'est à dire qu'après elle a pas pu
initialement elle a été retenue par un
engagement auprès du président de la
République ou du Premier ministre je me
rappelle plus honnêtement en tout cas
pas d'un événement important
et par conséquent le cabinet m'a fait
savoir que je serai reçu par le
directeur de cabinet et pendant une
heure nous avons discuté avec le
directeur du cabinet du projet encore
une fois ce que vous a dit le directeur
de cabinet est vrai à aucun moment il
n'y a eu d'engagement financiers ni de
sa part ni de la part de la ministre ni
de la part du cabinet d'accord
nous avons encore une fois affiner le
projet et il voulait se tenir au courant
pour le compte de la ministre des
détails des détails qui que que
recevait qui a pris ensuite la décision
donc de modifier le
montant du dépôt du dossier donc d'avoir
un deuxième dossier déposé à hauteur de
355000 euros monsieur karunagaran
quand je vous dis
c'est pas pour me dérober encore une
fois
d'accord donnez moi juste une réponse je
vous non non mais c'est ce que je suis
en train de faire en étant le plus
détaillé même si ça vous embête parce
que je pense que le l'heure du déjeuner
est proche etc et vous avez beaucoup
on va prendre si vous voulez bien le
temps qu'il faut pour que vous puissiez
comprendre OK et on va parler calmement
ne me venez pas me piquer au vif et je
demandais de garder mes nerfs je ne
viens donc je ne kiffe personne au vif
encore une fois
dès le moment où on rentre dans une
traduction
administrative et financière d'un projet
que j'ai porté intellectuellement je
remets l'ensemble des éléments que nous
avions préparés ensemble avec Cyril
caronagaran à Cyril caronagaran qui va
se charger de la traduction
administrative administrative de ce
projet en sa qualité en sa qualité cela
ne vous a pas échappé de président de
l'association d'accord et donc c'est lui
qui va mener l'ensemble des discussions
avec l'administration pour mettre en
application ce projet d'un point de vue
administratif et financier voilà et à
partir de là ce n'est pas pour me
dérober mais ça parce que ce n'est pas
mon rôle ce n'est pas mon rôle ce n'est
pas mon rôle et encore moins dans la
répartition des rôles qui étaient les
nôtres de rester en contact avec
l'administration j'ai bien compris
à plusieurs reprises la traduction
administrative j'allais vous poser la
question et financière mais vous avez
ajouté ce qui me paraît
cohérent moi j'ai juste besoin de
comprendre je vous dis la chronologie
des faits elle est différente séquences
c'est heureux que vous ayez s'il vous
plaît
n'ayons pas de remarque des obligeantes
ça ne sert à rien ça n'est jamais bon
pour je dirais la sérénités
des éléments complémentaires d'ailleurs
ont été déposés sur le dossier sur le
projet est-ce que ces éléments
vous ont été demandés et le cas échéant
à quel moment puisque pour passer avoir
un comment dirais-je un montant de
dossier supplémentaire dans le cadre du
Fonds mariage ça a été des échanges avec
le cabinet en lien non absolument pas
encore une fois je vous redis
factuellement ce que je vous ai dit et
qui est facilement
je dirais
qui peut être facilement vérifié puisque
tout ceci est documenté ce qui est
documenté ce sont des échanges
ininterrompus entre
pardon le cabinet de Monsieur Gravel ou
les services de Monsieur Gravel et Cyril
caronagan d'accord
ce sont ce sont ces deux personnes qui
enfin ces deux personnes c'est plusieurs
je sais pas si Cyril était en contact
avec une ou deux plusieurs personnes
monsieur rapporteur il était en contact
avec l'administration et c'est
l'administration qui lui demandait
d'ajuster de doux plusieurs versions que
vous avez probablement dans le dossier
plusieurs versions de CERFA de et même
des emails qui disent clairement
nous vous prions de toi alors Cyril car
on a garante qui envoie nous vous prions
de trouver ci-joint une version
actualisée de notre dossier de
candidature actualiser c'est à dire
qu'on lui a demandé d'actualiser et ça
c'est de 10 mai 2021 par la suite il
reçoit un autre email
comment dire visiblement de la personne
chargée de l'examen du dossier qui lui
dit je me permets de vous écrire au
sujet d'un problème dans votre demande
subvention nous sommes le 25 juin un
mois après un mois après la notification
monsieur le rapporteur le budget du
projet indique toutes leurs ressources
et non uniquement celle des actions etc
donc un mois après un mois après la
notification l'administration s'aperçoit
qu'il y aurait des erreurs ne vous
inquiétez pas j'étais même pas au mois
de juin mais c'est très bien vous vous
donnez des éléments il y a aucun
problème que les échanges je ne sais pas
comme d'autres ont dit moi je sais qui
était en contact et ces documenter très
bien
venons-en à l'objet de la le temps de la
réalisation du projet donc j'ai bien
compris le rôle que vous aviez porté qui
était dans ce projet qui était dans
naître je dirais la tête concente et la
avec la vision stratégique et
l'architecture de ce projet qui je le
devine vous a pris vous l'expliquer
beaucoup de temps
sachant sauf faire de ma part que votre
contrat de travail prévoyez un contrat
de travail à mi-temps c'est bien ça à
plein temps
bon voilà donc d'accord
oui mais je comme j'avais un doute par
rapport à des éléments avec
35 ans
de travail très supérieure à la normale
et j'apprécie un certain nombre de
personnes de par le monde qui vous
appréciez
votre déclaration je ne porte pas de
qualification sur vos capacités quelles
qu'elles soient je ne me permettrai pas
quel finalement quel regard portez-vous
aujourd'hui sur les réalisations qui ont
été financées avec les crédits du fond
Marianne par votre association l'uspm
est-ce que vous considérez quels sont je
dirais en tout point conforme à ce que
vous imaginiez à l'échelle de
l'enveloppe qui vous a été attribué
est-ce que vous avez rencontré des
difficultés ou des obstacles
particuliers qui vous amener à réduire
l'ambition revoir les moyens est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus par
rapport à tout le travail que vous avez
fourni en contrepartie de la subvention
accordée je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur à partir du moment où
nous avons signé la Convention et reçu
les fonds enfin juillet je précise que
les Francs et vous le savez qui ont été
versés mais c'est toujours mieux de le
rappeler c'est là à hauteur de 250 266
250 euros et non pas 357000 euros 266
250 euros
très vite nous sommes mis au travail
évidemment j'étais conscient que étant
donné que tout a été budgété sur 635000
euros il fallait tout diviser par 3 et
divisé par 3 notamment le nombre de
postes à créer c'est à dire que
j'ambitionnais de pouvoir compter sur
au moins 6 personnes la première année
et il fallait de fait
divisé par 3 c'est-à-dire qu'arrivée à
peu près trois personnes enfin pas par
un deux parce que c'était il y avait un
taux incompressible sinon il y avait
rien qui se réalisait surtout que
je dirais nous devions initialement
selon le projet investir l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux et donc par conséquent
il était question de lancer
des comptes internet assez vite et
d'être dans une production
je dirais de qualité afin de légitimer
l'identité que nous comptions créer en
l'occurrence ce collectif comme nous
l'avons appelé ce collectif illaique la
première difficulté que j'ai rencontré
c'est j'ai compris très vite et
davantage entre octobre en novembre que
je m'étais engagé dans un projet qui
était morning
pour la simple raison qu'il n'était plus
pérennisable puisque
j'ai compris à travers une discussion
avec Christian Gravel qu'il n'irait pas
vers un financement de l'année de
pour des raisons que j'ignore mais en
tout état de cause il m'a dit clairement
qui avant même le bilan en nous venions
à peine de commencer c'est à dire que
nous avions commencé
il y a eu un échange assez vif malgré la
sympathique on a mais très franc et oui
je suis comme ça tu vois parce que vous
savez la franchise c'est du respect
aussi quand on regarde les gens dans les
yeux en leur dise qu'on pense c'est les
respecter je ferme la parenthèse
donc on a eu un échange assez vif
sur le fait
qu'avec les moyens dont on me donnait
qui était très éloigné de ce qui était
validé initialement par le cabinet je ne
pouvais pas en l'état mettre en
application le projet et que valider par
le cabinet validé politiquement par le
cabinet le projet validé politiquement
par le projet mais pas le budget le
projet je dis bien le projet monsieur le
Président je parle du projet le projet
validé par le cabinet que de fait quand
je vous dis j'ai le projet d'acheter des
voitures
et je souhaiterais que vous les
financier vous pouvez me dire oui
j'accepte que vous achetiez des voitures
vous voyez
donc
la validation politique était très
éloignée de la traduction administrative
et financière du projet d'accord et on
est on est parti de quelque chose du
volonté politique qui a les mobiliser
des moyens
ah finalement une absence de volonté
politique la réduction de l'ambition ou
la communication la communication a été
faite avec tambour et trompette pardon
et plus rien c'est à dire dès le moment
où la ministre a capitalisé
politiquement à travers sa queue
communication totalement hallucinante
parce que d'abord il était question de
ne pas communiquer et ne pas faire de
publicité sur le sujet déjà pour la
sécurité des personnes déjà pour la
sécurité des personnes la tenue parole
ensuite non mais elle n'a jamais
communiqué
vous savez certains sujets il y a des
institutions dans ce pays qui
travaillent dans la discrétion qui n'ont
pas besoin qui n'ont pas besoin de
claironner sur tous les toits rappeler
ce qu'ils font et qui et qui sont très
efficaces dans ce qu'il fait les gens
qui commencent à claironner sur ce
qu'ils font sont ceux qui font le moins
générale mais sur l'objet on a bien
compris vous et d'autres nous ont
tenue des discours et des expressions
convergentes donc il y a pas de problème
donc à partir de là si vous voulez je
comprends en octobre que ce sera
difficilement réalisable
je fais malgré tout tous les efforts
pour essayer de monter quelque chose de
crédit je j'attire votre attention sur
une chose qui est essentielle et parce
que elle a été chez l'une des critiques
qui est formulée par les médias et
probablement aussi par vous même
par le rapport de l'igéa le pathétique
rapport de l'hygiène je peux vous dire
pourquoi je le traite de pathétique
c'est que est-ce qu'il y a un contrat ou
une convention qui donne
un chiffre
est-ce que si on aurait fait au lieu de
500 productions 1000 ça aurait été
suffisant ça aurait été insuffisant
en gros on vous dit on va vous financer
une armée pour aller combattre l'armée
de Poutine et finalement vous finance
une petite milice et on vous dit
pourquoi vous n'avez pas battu l'armée
de Poutine enfin c'est quand même
surréaliste vous avez des islamistes qui
ont 10 ans d'avance sur vous d'accord
attendez vous donner trois francs
l'association et vous vous demandez
pourquoi les résultats ne sont pas
suivis merci à ce stade si vous voulez
bien je vais poursuivre deux dernières
questions à ce stade votre préau de la
saison monsieur karena garan dans
l'audition auquel il a répondu
nous a déclaré que finalement aucune
demande complémentaire de subvention à
l'endroit notamment des deux régions ce
qui faisait partie du projet initial
n'avait été adressé pour
participer au cofinancement de votre
projet
ça peut s'entendre mais est-ce que vous
avez une explication sur le fait de
n'avoir pas même sollicité et adressé
ces deux demandes de subvention pourquoi
là pourquoi y avoir renoncé très en
amont
j'espère que j'accepterai que vous
entendrez ce que j'ai à vous dire
sincèrement
d'abord j'ai adressé une demande de
façon informelle et même plusieurs
demandes à des régions je les citerai
pas parce que c'est resté au stade de la
formelle et je vais vous dire les
réponses attendez juste le parce que
lequel ça se matérialise comment
l'information
par des rencontres des réunions que j'ai
sollicité parce que j'étais obligé
d'aller essayer de chercher un
complément donc j'ai sollicité des et on
m'a répondu clairement d'ailleurs l'un
de mes interlocuteurs a fait cette
boutade volontairement en me disant non
je ferai en sorte à ce que cette région
ne finance pas le fond Marlène
il a pas dit le fond Marianne le fond
marin pourquoi parce que elle a fait une
communication tellement personnelle à la
veille je vous rappelle quand même le
contexte mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous êtes des élus et vous
connaissez le cynisme politique mieux
que moi et vous l'exercer certainement
mieux que moi aussi la politique
pour le coup devriez retirer ce propos
parce que il faut pas vous dire ce que
vous avez dit donc je vous dis juste ce
qui m'a été dit et qui intègre une
logique de cynisme politique nous sommes
à la veille d'une élection
présidentielle des régions
qui avait des divergences politiques
avec Marlène Schiappa et le camp de
Marlène Schiappa
n'était pas je dirais très pompe à
soutenir un projet qui est devenu le
projet Marlène Schiappa et des gens de
votre camp mais les gens de votre camp
politique
c'est que des gens qui sont candidat à
la candidature
et pourquoi ça vous gêne
ah bon alors
si vous voulez je vais poursuivre
d'accord parce que nous avons encore un
centre de questions on voit que
certaines réponses vous gênent c'est
très bien
vous savez les Français ils regardent
ceux qui s'y intéressent ils porteront
le jugement qu'il souhaiteront ce qui
compte c'est que la démocratie puisse
exercer sereinement dans le respect à la
fois des débats et des personnes et
surtout du sujet
dire amen ne vous apporte rien et
n'apporte rien de constructif au débat
perdez moi de vous le dire une dernière
la question quel regard portez-vous sur
la demande de à la suite de l'inspection
générale de l'administration
qui vous est adressé de rembourser une
partie des sommes versées parce qu'elle
ne correspondrait pas à la convention
qui a été
objet de la subvention
fléchée à l'endroit de votre et au
bénéfice de votre association
d'abord je demanderai au rédacteur en
tout cas je conseillerais ne serait-ce
par respect pour l'administration au
rédacteur de ce rapport de corriger
quelques petites erreurs qui ne sont pas
si petites que ça puisqu'on peut pas
faire un rapport sur un tel sujet on se
trompant sur la date d'Ann assassinat
terroriste
donc
l'enseignant de Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
n'a pas été tué dans la date qui figure
dans le rapport ce qui peut paraître un
détail comme le dirait certains sur des
sujets importants mais qui n'est pas à
mes yeux en détail parce que ça montre
et ça prouve la légèreté et la
précipitation le manque de rigueur avec
lequel ce rapport a été écrit l'IGA est
dans une attitude d'auto légitimation de
l'administration en essayant de trouver
des lampes on n'est pas ici
va trouver des lampistes en l'occurrence
Cyril karunagaran et moi-même et
accessoirement monsieur Gravel vous avez
vous avez le droit d'avoir tous les avis
que vous souhaitez sur le revenu je vais
vous parler des erreurs
factuelles non vous intéresse pas
monsieur le Président non pas vraiment
je vais vous dire
attendez la question n'est pas celle-là
que vous ayez des commentaires à faire
sur un rapport où vous êtes cité c'est
la moindre des choses ça s'entend que
vous ayez une réponse à faire à lija
vous la ferez et vous leur donnerez vous
leur enverrez je le ferai pas enfin vous
en avez la liberté ce que je veux dire
faire voilà il y a aucun problème
là-dessus non nous on vous dit au-delà
de de ce truc restant sur le truc obligé
à vous demande
rien mais demande à l'administration de
demander un remboursement à peu près de
la moitié des montants que vous a été
alloué voilà avez-vous un commentaire à
faire sur ce point d'abord je conteste
le fond et la forme de certains des
accusations qui sont mentionnées je
prendrai l'une d'elles et pardon qui
montre en quoi encore la légèreté et la
médiocrité du texte en prétend que
l'USPPM aurait loué un bureau sans
l'utiliser
manque de chance c'est la chose qu'il
fallait pas écrire vous savez pourquoi
parce que dans ma triste vie je suis
accompagné tous les jours par deux
fonctionnaires de police au moins
donc votre commission d'enquête de façon
totalement officielle à se rapprocher du
service de la protection du ministère de
l'Intérieur et leur demander de vous
fournir un document qui pourrait
attester que chaque matin au sortir de
mon domicile mais officiers de sécurité
m'accompagnaient au bureau qui a été
loué pour le compte de la réalisation du
projet illaique donc là vous êtes sur
une réponse sur environ de mémoire je
suis humiliant de dépenses voilà je suis
sous serment et oui mais un
deux choses qui est totalement
gravissime on va jusqu'à vous expliquer
et expliquer elle est opinion publique
puisque c'est public
que Cyril caronagaran est peut-être
accessoirement moi-même Orient fait de
la butte faiblesse sur deux personnes
membres de l'association qui aurait
signé des documents qui peut-être
n'auraient-ils pas signé s'ils étaient
en plein possession de leurs moyens tout
ça parce que j'ai dit on audition on est
en totalement transparent comme je le
suis avec vous que nos deux amis
ont pour le premier eu un covidon
avec effectivement des difficultés de
santé et pour le second eu un problème
de santé qu'il a sauf que ils ont oublié
une chose ces deux personnes sont deux
gendarmes à la retraite l'un à des
activités associatives très régulières
il est médecin du GIGN et de second et
employé aujourd'hui dans une grande
entreprise où il gère la sécurité
comment on peut vous raconter qu'en gros
il y avait deux vieillards à côté de
nous qui étaient grabataire et dont on a
de la diffamation c'est ce jeu condamne
de la demande de remboursement je crois
pas que non pas du tout nous sommes dans
le sujet vous savez pourquoi nous sommes
dans le sujet parce que quand un rapport
est truffé de mensonges et de
contre-vérité j'irai moi même si c'est
pas moi qui serait sollicité c'est
l'association j'irai moi vous portez ce
combat devant les tribunaux je vais
porter le combat devant les tribunaux et
je vais te montrer je vais aider Cyril
carbonara à démontré que le
inapte et inapte ça relève de votre
appréciation toute personne le rembourse
et le remboursement ça sera une décision
de justice qui remboursement doit avoir
très bien
alors d'autres points
en mars 2022 il y a un avenant qui vous
est envoyé pour proroger du 28 février
2022 31 mai 2022 la période autour de
laquelle pour être réalisée le projet
illaïque puisqu'il a pris du retard au
démarrage on va dire bon
vous a-t-elle permis de terminer
certains projets le cas échéant lesquels
et j'ai a toujours mais n'allait pas ne
voyait pas ça comme une provocation si
je vous redis l'igéa n'a pas trouvé
trace de cet avenant en tout cas il lui
a pas fourni est-ce qu'il va être bien
été pris alors c'est une difficulté qui
a eu effectivement et dont j'ai eu
connaissance
je serai très vous dire avec précision
je crois à la rentrée 2000 2022
c'est-à-dire vers août septembre 2022
d'abord de la part de Cyril caronagarran
ensuite de la part de Christian Gravel
qui m'a fait savoir je parle de ce
dernier Christian Gravel qui m'a fait
savoir qu'il avait envoyé
qu'ils n'ont qu'il devait
un avenant devait être signé entre
l'association et ses services et que
manifestement Cyril carnagarone lui a
pas envoyé j'ai demandé à Cyril car on a
garant ce qu'il en était il m'a dit
qu'il l'avait envoyé mais que
visiblement l'administration n'avait pas
trouvé trace ils sont restés dans ce
dialogue jusqu'à je ne sais pas fin 2022
où une seconde ou une troisième fois
j'en sais rien cyril carnagarran a
envoyé un avenant recommandé
signé de par ses soins et n'a jamais
reçu la partie contre signé voilà ce que
je sais de cette de cet aspect de la
difficulté
très bien juste une dernière précision
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur si vous permettez parmi les
difficultés aussi que nous avons
rencontrées c'est que nos productions
j'étais obligé de les de les
disons les baissés à partir de janvier
février
pour une raison double d'abord on savait
que nous ne pouvions pas en tout cas
l'association ne pouvait pas reconduire
des CDD des deux rédacteurs parfois de
moyens et la deuxième chose
on était rentré dans une dans une
période de campagne électorale et par
conséquent il devenait très difficile
de traiter la plupart des sujets qui
étaient les nôtres puisque les sujets
qui étaient les nôtres étaient prérempés
d'une certaine façon par deux chapelles
idéologiques extrémistes d'extrême
droite je ne vais pas vous citer les
deux candidats d'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche je ne vais pas vous
citer les candidats d'extrême gauche on
est rentré dans cette contradiction et
je dois vous dire que Christian Gravel
m'avait appelé pour me dire de faire
très attention à ne pas
faire deux tweets qui pourraient polluer
la pré campagne ou ensuite la campagne
électorale je m'y étais engagé et
d'ailleurs après c'est sans me parler de
l'association en question il m'a dit
qu'il avait des difficultés avec une
association et qu'il voulait attirer mon
attention parce qu'il savait qu'on était
d'une certaine façon plutôt susceptibles
de
contredire pour utiliser un euphémisme
un certain nombre de candidats qui
portaient des valeurs qui étaient bien
éloignées de celles que nous défendons
bien monsieur Sifaoui nous avons
entendu sur ce point donc pas trace de
l'avenant signée vous confirmez la
position de l'hygia sur ce point bon
d'après les échanges du courriel est
téléphonique qui nous ont été transmis
l'association semble avoir été et quand
on dit semble c'est pour vous permettre
pour nous permettre de vous poser une
question mais nous avons une petite
appréciation sur le semble avoir été
très peu réactive aux demandes du
secrétaire général au point même de
cesser de répondre aux sollicitations
entre novembre 2022 et février 2023 et
là comme vous dites voilà on a tous les
éléments sur ce point
est-ce que vous nous expliquer pourquoi
alors là aussi et en fait ça accrédit de
ce que je disais tout à l'heure qu'il
n'y avait chez moi aucune posture
ce n'est pas moi qui était qui n'était
pas joignable on vous a pas dit qu'à un
moment donné moi-même cifaoui n'était
pas joignable j'ai appris effectivement
que Cyril caronagaran porte dans une
période n'était pas été difficilement
joignable je les je lui ai demandé pour
quelle raison il n'arrivait pas à se
rendre disponible il m'a fait savoir
qu'il avait des problèmes personnels de
d'état de santé lié à des proches et
qu'il allait très vite faire diligence
pour répondre aux sollicitations voilà
ce que je sais
merci
alors un point qui est un point
qui d'ailleurs fait lien avec ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez
dit tout à l'heure
je l'ai noté la dès le mois d'octobre je
savais que le projet était
fichu quoi bon enfin il y avait une
difficulté puisqu'il y avait plus du
tout la notion de continuité dans le
temps etc bon vous avez dit ça vous avez
dit aussi d'ailleurs que dès le départ
dès que vous avez compris ça vous avez
réduit les charges de manière assez
significative bon en tout cas vous
n'êtes pas engagé sur du long terme ce
qu'on peut comprendre si vous aviez
cette cette pensée mais pour autant vous
avez réduit les charges mais pas toutes
les charges et vous voyez où je vais en
venir c'est à dire que en réalité quand
on regarde la la règle
de subventionnement qui est lié à un
système de 60% mais 60% sur l'ensemble
du projet pas 60% sur la somme qui vous
est
dévoluer évidemment
quand on regarde la réalité des charges
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve et bien on
retrouve essentiellement
de salaire principaux quelques salaires
complémentaires et très peu de frais
annexes
donc
si je voulais le dire bon en tenant
compte de ce que vous avez dit vous avez
réduit les charges mais pas sur vos deux
principaux salaires qui étaient quand
même le point majeur quoi du système à
ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer cela
d'abord
l'ensemble de nos chaleurs représentées
effectivement me semble-t-il 80% de de
la subvention l'ensemble des salaires et
c'est un peu moins
ah bah c'est très bien vous voyez c'est
toujours vous voyez que nous sommes
voilà très bien j'en doute pas monsieur
le Président en tout cas c'est le lever
je crois de mémoire à 140.000 euros pour
l'ensemble des quatre salaires et en
plus un delta de prestataire extérieur
de l'ordre de 40 000 euros je crois
nous sommes substantiellement loin de
des chiffres avancés par par certains
médias et je tiens à le souligner parce
que
évidemment
ne n'étant pas visiblement de grands
professionnels de l'investigation ils
ont mélangé ceux qui les rémunérations
établies sur les fonds propres de
l'association et le les salaires
imputables sur le fond Marianne nous
parlons bien des salaires imputables sur
le fond Marianne sur le fond Marianne
les salaires imputables qui m'ont été
versés personnellement sont de l'ordre
de 43000 euros sur 12 mois 43000 euros
et pardonnez-moi du Mans déclaré auprès
de l'administration fiscale
sherylcaronagarra son salaire mais je
crois que c'était autour de 30 000 euros
imputables sur le fond mariage un peu
plus donc à deux c'est 77000 euros de
salaire imputable sur le frontal donc le
reste c'est par conséquent la chose
effectivement
qui n'était pas possible c'était de
réduire de réduire enfin réduire nos
salaires c'est mettre fin à nos contrats
de travail c'est soit passer à une
attitude de bénévole mais à ce moment-là
il fallait parce que bon
accessoirement je tiens à le dire je
n'ai pas centré ma vie autour de la vie
de la chose matérielle et donc je ne
suis pas rentier et comme je suis père
de famille et que j'ai des enfants à
élever il me faut gagner ma vie et
gagner ma vie à une hauteur qui me
permette justement de faire face au
quotidien pas pour un enrichissement
personnel pas pour un doucement personne
ça n'a jamais été ma quête d'existence
et donc oui il fallait qu'on ait un
salaire
je n'ai pas rougir face à ce salaire et
je le dis devant vous ce salaire est
conforme un contrat de travail et lié un
travail qui a été fourni c'est un
travail qui a été fourni et qui a été
apprécié uniquement sur sa partie
publiable et visible comme si lorsqu'on
se réveille le matin qu'on fait une
revue de presse pour le compte du projet
ce n'est pas du travail comme si
lorsqu'on reçoit un appel téléphonique à
22h pour pour corriger monsieur shifaoui
on est d'accord avec vous qui a une
partie de travail toujours heureusement
d'ailleurs masqué intellectuel de
préparation vous dites un professeur il
corriger copie évidemment que nous
savons tous à non
rapport de l'igéa moi j'ai pas de
compétences le fameux rapport de
l'hygiène
mais quand même quand on regarde même
nous quand on regarde la quand même le
nombre de Visio
nombre de tweets de trucs qui se passe
ça nous paraît faible on peut on peut on
peut le dire de manière courtoise ça
paraît faible d'autre part si vous
voulez
vous nous dites un peu ce projet à un
moment donné bon vous avez compris qu'il
n'allait pas aller beaucoup plus loin
et donc ça se traduit un petit peu
et vous nous dites aussi quelque chose
qui est tout à fait
confirmé que vous avez été mis en garde
sur tel ou tel sujet ou tel ou telle
façon de traiter les sujets dans le
cadre de la campagne des campagnes
électorales qui allait arriver tout ça
tout ça est vrai mais au final au final
ça fait une production extrêmement
faible par voilà extrêmement faible par
rapport à je veux dire que des gens plus
qualifiés que moi le diront nous ici on
fait un constat comme ça un peu général
mais on trouve que ça fait quand même un
truc relativement faible et pas
sûr vous souhaitez continuer votre
question je sais pas peut-être dans le
prolongement juste je suis dans le
prolongement pour bien faire le lien
mais simplement
il semblerait aussi on a eu des
confirmations sur ce point que l'équipe
que vous avez recruté en fait c'était
quoi ça a été de poster 2000 en réalité
entre les mi-temps voilà c'était de
l'ordre de deux possibles bon au départ
il y a eu des relations
tout à fait classique avec la mission
qui était la vôtre c'est-à-dire
l'orientation c'était vous qui la fixiez
le contrôle
a posteriori de ce qui était produit et
des réflexions sur comment modifier puis
à partir d'un certain moment mais assez
tôt et qui correspond assez bien ce que
vous dites c'est-à-dire le mois
d'octobre c'est le moment où il y a un
peu de flou sur l'opération et sur la
continuité de l'opération
là par contre plus de son plus d'image
et donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à ce moment-là
d'abord vous me donnez l'occasion de et
je tiens puisqu'il y a ce temps debout
aussi et que c'est extérieur pas vous
qui alimente cette polémique à rendre
hommage aux deux rédacteurs qui ont
travaillé avec nous qui ont fait preuve
de sérieux
d'une grande qualité professionnelle et
j'espère qu'ils ne seront jamais mêlés à
cette affaire ni de près ni de loin
parce qu'ils n'ont absolument rien à se
reprocher j'assume seul sur le plan
éditorial la responsabilité
et les critiques et
les mécontentements des uns et des
autres et les considérations subjectives
et les accusations mensongères et je
veux revenir au sujet ça c'est non mais
c'est important non mais je comprends
le président
jouent leur tranquillité les gens jouent
leur avenir c'est pas quelque chose de
simple que de jouer que jeter des gens
au chien pour reprendre une expression
connue est-ce qu'on s'est permis de
livrer quelques noms que ce soit vous
merci je tiens à le dire parce que il y
a certains journalistes irresponsables
qui sont dans une sorte de vente d'État
idéologique qui sont capables de tout et
n'importe quoi voilà je ferme la
parenthèse
concernant ces deux
collaborateurs amis
par participant activement à la
naissance de
je n'ai pas eu de désaccord majeur avec
eux ils m'est arrivé je vais utiliser un
gros mot que je n'aime pas du tout parce
que c'est une situation très
inconfortable que de devoir entre
guillemets censurer et production pas
pour pas pour pour
le plaisir de censurer pas pour attenter
à la liberté d'expression absolument pas
mais pour être conforme un cahier
d'échange et faire preuve de
responsabilité la difficulté que à
laquelle j'étais confronté monsieur
président monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est que nous sommes sur des
thématiques
qui sont investis par un certain nombre
d'acteurs politiques alors je me suis
permis de laisser répondre à et de
répondre moi-même à certains acteurs
avant descendre avant décembre c'est à
dire avant l'entrée en pré campagne
je peux vous jeter le nom si vous le
souhaitez des responsables politiques et
j'assume totalement c'est moi donc si
jamais demain il voit leur nom Éric
Zemmour Sandrine Rousseau c'est moi
voilà c'est pas c'est pas l'association
c'est moi qui ai répondu c'est moi qui
ai pris choix de répondre avec le compte
de l'association à des inepsies là pour
des propos racistes et xénophobe l'autre
pour le soutien aux voies islamiste le
problème c'est qu'à partir de septembre
on ne pouvait plus à partir de pardon
décembre janvier ne pouvait plus et ça
devenait de plus en plus compliqué de
répondre de répondre sur le ton juste
de ne pas s'exposer à des poursuites
éventuelles
j'ai voulu incarner le projet j'ai voulu
l'incarner pourquoi l'incarner pour
pouvoir
identifier le collectif les gens y
compris qu'ils nous considéraient
de leur bord idéologique était en été
pour eux un collectif anonyme même des
amis n'étaient pas au courant que
j'étais à la tête de ce projet parce
qu'on nous m'a demandé on m'a demandé de
rester très discret sur et on m'a
empêché de de l'incarner au même titre
que je devais faire en sorte à ce qu'il
y a une porte-parole sur sur ce projet
une personne je dirais figure médiatique
qui aille et j'avais en tête la personne
qui devait jouer ce rôle on m'a refusé
ça donc si vous voulez un moment donné
il faut bien comprendre ce qu'on est en
train de raconter dans cette histoire on
vous demande de vous lancer dans un
projet on vous le valide et ensuite on
vous dépouille au fur et à mesure de
l'avancement donc évidemment la
production ne peut pas suivre moi je me
lancerai jamais dans un projet qui
consiste à faire deux trois dixites par
jour ça n'a pas de sens et Twitter de
façon frénétique tous les spécialistes
vous le diront ça n'a pas de sens c'est
quand on est dans un compte
institutionnel j'ai twitté pendant une
époque sur un compte Mon Compte
Personnel énormément mais sur mon compte
personnel sur un compte institutionnel
ensuite différemment forcément donc
la même chose on parle d'une on parle
d'une feuille blanche
tout est à créer
un compte sur chaque réseau social et
donc si vous voulez à chaque fois avec
une matière assez
originale pour pouvoir attirer
l'attention
donc aujourd'hui si vous voulez bien sûr
que je ne suis pas content des résultats
si vous voulez que je vous dise que je
suis satisfait de moi je suis pas je
suis pas content de moi je regrette
profondément et je ne ferai plus jamais
confiance aux institutions je le dire
qui m'engage qui m'engagerait à aller
dans un travail je ferai confiance dans
voilà des relations comme ça mais jamais
jamais plus je ne suivrai
des demandes
d'un responsable politique jamais plus
plus personne sauf dans un cadre comme
celui-ci où je suis contraint ne
modifionnera plus jamais je n'échangerai
sur mes thématiques avec aucun
responsable politique parce que j'ai
perdu confiance totalement
totalement dans l'action publique où je
vois d'ailleurs les lâchetés se
manifester par la suite il aurait fallu
que chacun assume ses responsabilités sa
petite part de responsabilité chacun a
sa petite part de responsabilité je l'ai
dit en début d'intervention il y a pas
de malversation financière dans cette
affaire il n'y en a pas il n'y avait pas
une volonté de malversation financière
il y a des erreurs successives
encore une fois ce n'est pas ici je le
dis donc voilà
il n'y en a pas eu de la part de
personnes bien sûr de moi-même mais je
m'engage j'ai compris pour les autres
voilà il y en a pas vu non ce que je
veux dire c'est que ce qui décideront
d'éventuels mais elle va se financière
ce n'est pas nous très bien et vous le
savez et vous le savez donc nous névons
pas ce type de sujet nous essayons de
comprendre vous venez de donner les
éléments d'appréciation votre Vérité si
je peux dire non pas sur des questions
de malversation financière mais c'est
des questions de le fonctionnement du
projet pourquoi il a démarré en retard
nous le savons il a démarré en retard
pour beaucoup d'associations pas que la
vôtre pourquoi
pourquoi il s'est arrêté tout voilà en
tout cas il était empêché tôt ou mis en
difficulté tôt voilà et au final quel
est le résultat vous dites le résultat
bon
vous n'avez pas satisfait voilà on reste
je reste sur vos mots voilà et et je
crois que c'est ce que nous venions
chercher vos explications dans cette
dans cette dans cette affaire la
compréhension des sujets vu par tous les
acteurs ce que nous avons vu et
effectivement en tout état de cause la
reconnaissance de responsabilité est
toujours un peu difficile à venir
naturellement voilà ce que ce qu'on peut
vous laisser l'ensemble et c'est
l'ensemble des auditions qui l'ont
montré voilà ça mais j'espère que vous
les aiderez aussi moi en tout cas je
suis là je suis pas responsable
politique je suis pas dans
l'administration à mon modeste niveau
j'assume l'ensemble de mes
responsabilités et la première erreur
que j'ai faite c'est d'avoir fait
confiance à Madame Schiappa aux équipes
de Madame Schiappa et d'avoir
foncé un peu parce que j'ai vous savez
j'ai des défauts comme tout le monde
et j'ai
qualité peut-être
c'est la sincérité la naïveté parfois
des gens engagés je suis quelqu'un
d'engagé monsieur le Président je suis
pas à quel moment je suis quelqu'un
d'engagé comme vous et vous savez les
gens engagés ont parfois cette naïveté
de croire que les autres sont aussi
engagés que et quand vous êtes face au
cynisme
vous oubliez parfois que vous pouvez
être manipulé utilisé par le pouvoir
politique ça a été mon cas et par
prolongement j'ai entraîné dans mon
sillage lui seppm Cyril caronagaran et
évidemment tous ceux qui voilà
merci Monsieur cifaoui merci de cette
audition merci Monsieur Lucifer oui je
me dois de vous dire que à titre
personnel de nos échanges je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure mais je vous confirme
que ça j'ai relevé tout de même un
certain nombre de contradictions entre
les déclarations des uns et des autres
lors des auditions j'ai
je l'ai parfois mentionné voilà je et en
général je fais des choses à visage
découvert comme vous l'avez vu en toute
franchise par contre et je le dis sans
aucune pensée accusatrice le président
et moi-même élément de la commission des
finances qui ont assisté à l'ensemble ou
à certaines des auditions ont pu en tous
les cas apprécier jusqu'à maintenant la
tenue des travaux ça n'empêche que les
uns les autres peuvent avoir des
expressions plus affirmée voilà avec en
mettant un ton très engagé simplement
et pour terminer je vous redis que je
regrette et je pense que vous j'espère
que c'est aussi votre cas vous n'avez
ici en face de vous et à vos côtés
pas de personnes qui ont voulu d'une
manière ou d'une autre manifester du
cynisme
on essaie simplement d'établir la
réalité des faits et ensuite d'en tirer
les enseignements pour la clarté du
débat public je vous remercie monsieur
le Président je vous remercie monsieur
le rapporteur j'entends vos propos je
vous remercie de la qualité de l'échange
je vous ai répondu franchement j'ai dit
les choses telles que je les pensais et
le cynisme viser notamment ceux qui
utilisent cette commission d'enquête
veulent se faire un petit peu les danges
je dirais politiquement parlant sur des
personnes qui sont par ailleurs traînées
dans la boue avant même que la justice
ne s'exprime ce n'est pas la première
fois que le pouvoir politique ou des
élus se substituts au pouvoir judiciaire
je vous remercie merci monsieur
votre audition traditionnelle à la fin
des travaux de la commission d'enquête
et de la mission parlementaire
d'information et des missions
parlementaires d'information intervient
deux jours à peine après l'annonce d'une
liste de 450 médicaments essentiels
de votre collègue du gouvernement Roland
Lescure mise à veget chargé de
l'Industrie une première liste de 280
médicaments avaient été publiés avec un
peu de ma liste nous pourrions croire
que nos travaux rythmes avantageusement
la communication du gouvernement en
matière de pénurie de médicaments mais
je n'oserais aller plus loin dans
l'interprétation de la situation
la publication de la liste de ces
quelques 450 médicaments essentiels
marquent une nouvelle étape de la
feuille de route pénurie et vous pourrez
nous préciser selon quel processus elle
a été établie entre consultations des
sociétés savantes retour d'expérience de
la société française d'anesthésie
réanimation intervention de la Société
française de pharmacie clinique et
discussion avec le comité d'organisation
dans la mesure nous avions déjà eu un
échange avec la Direction générale des
entreprises sur la constitution de la
première liste et donc on aimerait
savoir ce qui entre la liste d'origine
les fameux 58 premiers qui avaient été
validés le premier médicament validé
qu'elle est un peu l'évolution entre
entre les deux et est-ce que le process
est resté le même le président de la
République a par ailleurs annoncé la
constitution d'une alors je cite liste
cœur
peut-être est-ce la liste de que
j'évoquais liste cœur d'une cinquantaine
de médicaments essentiels pour lesquels
notre dépendance aux importations
extra-européennes est avérée ou dont la
production française est insuffisante
pour par rapport à la demande qu'il faut
et qu'il faut donc relocaliser sans nous
révéler le contenu de cette liste vous
pourrez je l'espère nous indiquer dans
quel délai elle sera finalisée et ce et
selon quelle méthode
et est-ce que cela sous-entend le
corollaire que les 400 autres ne sont
pas concernés par les problèmes de
production en tout cas ne sont pas mis
au même niveau que c'est que ces 50
quelques 50 choisis en outre je souhaite
que vous puissiez nous dire comment le
calendrier des relocalisations annoncées
mardi a été établie car nous n'oublions
pas qu'il y a 3 ans quasiment jour pour
jour le président de la République avait
annoncé que la France serait en mesure
d'ici trois ans de reproduire
conditionner et distribuer du
paracétamol
mais l'usine séquence de Roussillon nous
nous avons visité le chantier devrait
entrer en production d'ici 2025
seulement donc nous explicités pourquoi
le délai même si on imagine aisément
qu'il y a des raisons
essentielles à cela les mesures de
relocalisation de la production
s'inscrivent donc d'évidence dans la
durée mais pendant ce temps les pénuries
continuent
assis j'ai été alerté il y a deux jours
sur la pénurie de bétail un
anti-vertinegineux qui n'est certes pas
un MTM selon la terminologie de la NSM
et
terminologie que nous utilisons la LSM
le considère néanmoins comme d'usage
très élevé puisqu'il concerne plus de 40
000 patients chaque année ceci pose par
ailleurs d'ailleurs la question de
l'approvisionnement de médicaments
essentiels pour la qualité de vie des
malades mais réglementairement non
considérés comme tel vous nous direz
comment vous entendez dialoguer avec les
associations de patients concernés par
ce type de difficulté je pourrais
également citer par exemple certains
traitements contre la maladie
de toute façon contenu de la liste des
3500 médicaments en pénurie tout un tas
de situations extrêmement problématiques
qu'on parle d'anticancéreuses
spécifiques pour certains cancers
hématologiques ou alors de
d'anti-épileptiques
qui sont prescrits sous forme
pédiatrique
enfin il y a quelques semaines les
pédiates de 5 pays européens dont la
France ont déjà alerté sur les risques
de pénurie à l'automne prochain
quelles assurances pouvez-vous nous
donner sur les moyens mis en oeuvre pour
faire en sorte que les difficultés
graves rencontrées à l'hiver dernier ne
se reproduisent pas
au-delà de l'intitulé plomb blanc c'est
bien sûr sur le contenu de ce plan que
nous vous interrogeons car qu'il soit
blanc rouge ou d'une autre couleur
clairement c'est la façon dont les
choses doivent se dérouler et nous nous
situons
suffisamment en amont en tout cas pour
que nous voyons clairs au niveau des
stocks et de la disponibilité des
médicaments avant la crise d'épidémique
et hivernale à la rentrée de septembre
surtout ces sujets je vais maintenant
vous céder la parole pour un bref repoin
introductif puis madame Laurence Cohen
rapporteur de notre commission d'enquête
vous posera une première série de
questions je précise que cette audition
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu publié avant
de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête est passible
des peines prévues aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vous y invite donc à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
en levant la main droite et en disant
que je le jure
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole
merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs
je sais et vous venez de le rappeler
[Musique]
il y a que des dames il y a que des
dames excusez-moi oui je sais c'est
mesdames
donc mesdames laissez la tristes je sais
d'avancement de vos travaux et je vais
reprendre des éléments un petit peu
généraux et bien sûr je serai à votre
entière disposition pour répondre aux
questions plus précises ou pour préciser
certains points comme vous l'avez fait
remarqué madame la Présidente dans la
suite des débats alors la question de la
pénurie de médicaments est pas une
question récente elle existe quasiment
depuis depuis toujours en tout cas en
tant que médecin hospitalier je l'ai
connu très régulièrement à des périodes
pas systématiquement l'hiver d'ailleurs
depuis un an la situation a été
particulièrement regardée
particulièrement regarder par une
meilleure un meilleur signalement de ces
risques de rupture et de pénurie par la
NSM qui s'est équipée des outils
nécessaires mais également avec des un
choc ou des chocs exogènes sur le
circuit du médicament et l'industrie du
médicament bien sûr la en Ukraine qui a
produit des difficultés principalement
dans les outils de conditionnement et
puis cette phase post covid qui a
complètement modifié la la perception
que l'on pouvait avoir de de ces
consommations de médicaments avec une
période qui a été très concentrée sur
certains types de médicaments par
exemple paracétamol - sur d'autres les
antibiotiques puisque les mesures de
protection qui ont été prises avaient
diminuées la prescription de ces mêmes
antibiotiques nous avons connu cet hiver
des difficultés importantes sur deux de
ces produits bien entendu de paracétamol
et de l'amoxicilline principalement dans
leur forme pédiatrique on pourra revenir
si vous le souhaitez sur ces sur ces
difficultés très particulières alors
quel a été la réaction que ce que j'ai
voulu mettre en place face à ces
pénuries vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente une feuille de route pénurie
un plan pénurie avec un premier le
principe qui était l'établissement des
médicaments essentiels cette fameuse
liste publiée il y a deux jours pourquoi
publier une liste de ces médicaments
essentiels et bien pour mieux les
identifier mieux les surveiller mieux
les contrôler et identifier pour chacun
de ces médicaments réaliser une
cartographie des risques depuis la
production du principe actif jusqu'à la
distribution des boîtes en pharmacie je
pense qu'il est important ici de bien
souligner l'importance de ce dispositif
de cet éventail absolument complet en ce
qui concerne l'amoxicilline cet hiver
par exemple j'ai pu constater une une
différence entre des industriels me
disant que les stocks étaient là et
qu'ils arrivaient à produire et les
pharmaciens me disant au même moment
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à voir les boîtes
dans les pharmacies donc toutes cette
chaîne de de non seulement de production
mais également de distribution est
extrêmement importante à prendre en
compte
dans cette dans les mesures à prendre
bien entendu en dehors des mesures qui
ont été très
conjoncturelles cet hiver comme
les possibilités pour les pharmaciens de
distribuer